Hey guys, so if I had a dollar for every time somebody comes up to me and asks me what my morning routine is, I'd be like a billionaire. Here's what my morning routine is. I get up and then I brush my teeth. Welcome to SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess.
大家好，如果别人每次来问我早起习惯是什么，我都能拿一美元的话，那我就是个亿万富翁了。这就是我的早起习惯。我起床，然后刷牙。欢迎收看《SmartLess》。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。
SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess.
SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。
SmartLess. SmartLess. So, will, had a dinner party the other night that I was invited to. Sean was invited to. We were both there. You were invited to as well, but you were working down in Atlanta. And about halfway through it, maybe halfway. Someone said, yeah, Sean has got it left.
SmartLess。SmartLess。威尔，前几天你办了个晚宴，我被邀请了，西恩也被邀请了，我们俩都在。你也受邀了，但你当时在亚特兰大工作。大概进行到一半的时候，也许是一半吧，有人说，对了，西恩已经走了。
They're gone. They're gone. So now's your chance. I haven't seen you talk to you since. Did you have sickness or something? I have this thing about the dog. I have this thing about like leaving the dog for more than four hours. The dog that he left for eight months in New York, he's worried about leaving for four hours for him. Yeah, exactly Sean. Yeah, no, no, no, no, no, because the dog was left alone. Yeah, exactly, Sean. Same thing. No, I'll be picked up from there.
他们走了。他们走了。所以现在是你的机会。从那以后我还没见过你，也没跟你说过话。你当时是生病了吗什么的？我这人对狗有点执念。我有那种不能把狗独自留在家超过四个小时的执念。他把狗在纽约扔了八个月不管，现在却担心把狗独自留在家四个小时。对，没错，西恩。对，不，不，不，不，不，因为当时狗是被单独留下的。对，没错，西恩。一回事。不，我会从那儿接话的。
No, because the dog was left alone. The dog was left alone. So when the dog's left alone here at the house, who doesn't leave their dogs alone? I know, but not that long. I have like a thing about it. Well, you got to get over that thing because that excuse is so outrageous that-
不，因为当时狗是被单独留下的。狗被单独留下了。所以当狗被独自留在家里时，谁不会把狗独自留在家里？我知道，但不会留那么久。我就是有点这种执念。好吧，你得克服这种执念，因为这个借口太离谱了，以至于——
But that is not an excuse. And it's a long life. It's a long life. You can't be tethered to your house for a while. But when you tell people I got to go because I'm worried about leaving my dog for four hours, they're just going to think you're rude because no one's going to believe that that's a real thing. Well, I'm telling you what's the right, but what if I'm telling you it's a real thing? Well, then they should say you should go to therapy because it's an irrational fear.
但这不是借口。人生路漫漫。人生还很长。你总不能一直被拴在家里吧。但当你告诉别人“我得走了，因为我担心把狗独自留在家里四个小时”时，他们只会觉得你很粗鲁，因为没人会相信这是真事。好吧，我在告诉你这是真的，但如果我告诉你这是真事呢？那他们就会说你应该去看心理医生，因为这是一种不理性的恐惧。
Well, I don't know. What do you think people do? Have you ever seen anyone go to work? If you ever seen real people go to a job before? You know, like an eight hour job, which is a show. You see all those people that you see filled on the buses and you're wondering like, fuck, why is this bus holding my lane now? Well, there must be so many dogs on the real world.
好吧，我不知道。你觉得别人都在干什么？你见过有人去上班吗？你以前见过真正的普通人去工作吗？你知道的，就像那种八小时的工作，也就是个节目。你看到那些挤满公交车的人，你心里想，操，为什么这辆公交车现在挡着我的车道？好吧，现实世界里一定有好多狗。
All the dogs are dying while they're on the bus. Those dogs must die all day. Jesus Christ. All those buses that are filled with people going to do real hard work. Well, you're- Just a bunch of dog murderers. Well, you're watching to go get your fucking eyes checked. They have a healthy relationship with their pet. They they have left the pet in the pet. You know what? It's a little lower on the
所有的狗在他们坐公交车的时候都在死。那些狗肯定一整天都在死。天哪。所有那些挤满人的公交车，他们去干真正辛苦的工作。好吧，你是——简直就是一群杀狗犯。好吧，你得去检查一下你那该死的眼睛。他们和宠物保持着健康的交往。他们把宠物留在了宠物。你知道吗？这在优先级列表里排名比较靠后，你知道我的意思吗？
list of priorities, you know what I mean? No, Sean, you would have you would have had you stayed. You would have seen me have one of my low points. Yes. Well, Amanda told me. So I told our host. I've told my host a few times, anyone that'll listen, I've probably bored you guys with it before, that my kryptonite is giving toast. I just can't do it. There's something about it that doesn't make, it's not comfortable for me. I do very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, part. Well, that's just, I guess so. Yeah, and instead I'm thinking about me and embarrassing myself, and I should just be
不，西恩，要是你留下来了，你就会看到我的低谷期之一。是的。好吧，阿曼达告诉我。所以我告诉了我们的节目主持人。我跟我节目的主持人提过好几次，凡是愿意听的人我都说过，我可能之前也拿这个烦过你们，我的软肋就是致祝酒词。我就是做不来。这事儿总让我觉得不舒服。我非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、而是在状况之外。好吧，那就这样吧。是的，相反，我满脑子都在想我自己，在出洋相，我本应该
kind of just channeling love for the other person, but that's a great note. I'm going to use that next time. But anyway, I didn't think about it at the time, and the host drops a microphone on my hand, and I totally froze up. No. And you forgot where you were. I didn't even think I could have just bailed out and said, you know what? Happy birthday.
将爱倾注在对方身上，但这真是一个绝佳的建议。下次我一定用这个。不过不管怎样，当时我没想到这一层，主持人把话筒塞到我手里，我整个人彻底僵住了。不会吧。而且你连自己在哪儿都忘了。我当时甚至没想过自己可以临阵脱逃，说句：“你知道吗？生日快乐。”
I didn't even think that. I thought I had to come up with a bit. I thought I had to do it like a set. So what did you do? And I said, I literally set out loud, oh my God, think of a good dad joke. And I couldn't even think of one of the many that you've told me. And I just looked up at him. I must have looked so horrified and pathetic.
我连这都没想到。我以为我得想个段子出来。我以为我得像说单口喜剧那样表演。那你当时干了什么？我 literally（简直）大声说出来，哦天哪，快想个好笑的老爸笑话。我甚至连你跟我讲过的那么多笑话一个都想不起来了。我只是抬头看着他。我当时看起来一定吓坏了，而且十分可悲。
So why not? He looked at me with such pity and just slowly pulled the microphone back out of my hand. No. And moved on to someone else. Yeah, well, you, that's not, it's not for you. It's not your thing. It's not like I can't do it. It's interesting. I mean, if you, if we think about it, considering how you've been performing since, yeah, you were such a little kid, but I get it. So I think different about a microphone, a spotlight, and a state. I don't, I'm not comfortable with it either. I mean, you know, but you know what though?
那为什么不呢？他用那种充满怜悯的眼神看着我，然后慢慢把话筒从我手里抽了回去。不会吧。然后转向了别人。好吧，好吧，你，那不是，那不适合你。这不是你的风格。倒也不是说我做不来。这很有意思。我的意思是，如果你，如果我们仔细想想，考虑到你从——以来一直以来的表演，是的，你当时还是个小不点儿，但我懂。所以我对麦克风、聚光灯和舞台的看法有所不同。我对此也感到很不自在。我的意思是，你知道的，但你知道吗？
I have a good friend who forced me to, anytime I went to her house, she would make people stand up and give speeches. And at, Jay, at your birthday, like two, three years ago, I started the speech thing, remember at Richard's house? Yeah. And I was like, oh, get up,
我有个好朋友，她逼着我，我每次去她家，她都会让大家站起来做演讲。在，杰伊，你两三年前的生日上，我带头搞了演讲这出戏，还记得在理查德家吗？对。当时我说，哦，站起来，
everybody say something nice about Jason. And I, I do it because I'm scared of it, because I'm like, oh, get up. Everybody say something nice about Jason. And I do it because I'm scared of it, because I'm like, I have to work through whatever this is about public. What's that? Leaning into the fear. Yeah, leaning into the fear. And every time you do it, it gets better and better.
每个人都说点夸奖杰森的好话。我这么做是因为我对此感到害怕，因为我想，哦，站起来。每个人都说点夸奖杰森的好话。我这么做是因为我害怕，因为我想，我必须克服这种对于公开演讲的……怎么说呢？直面恐惧。对，直面恐惧。而且你每次这么做，都会一次比一次好。
Well, I hope so, because that was very humbling. Let's get our guest take on how fucking rude Sean is and what a baby I am. I pulled a back girl. Here we go. So guys, today we got a fellow who is funny, okay, but he's not just funny. He's also smart. He went to Georgetown for Christ's sake.
好吧，但愿如此，因为那次经历真是太让人谦卑了。让我们听听我们的嘉宾对西恩到底有多混蛋以及我是个多大的婴儿有什么高见吧。我们开始吧。所以各位，今天我们迎来了一位非常搞笑的家伙，好吧，但他不仅搞笑。他还很聪明。他可是上了乔治城大学的。
His mom is a nurse, his dad's a doctor, but he's not just smart either, guys. He also is our least favorite word. He's a storyteller. No kidding. A better real one. So is our least favorite word? He's a storyteller. No kidding. But a real one. I like. Some folks have referred to it as a comedic monologue, but he's not just that either.
他妈妈是个护士，爸爸是个医生，但各位，他不仅聪明。他还是我们最讨厌的一个词。他是个故事讲述者。说真的。一个真正的故事讲述者。所以是我们最讨厌的词？他是个故事讲述者。说真的。但确实是个真的。我喜欢。有些人称之为喜剧独白，但他不仅于此。
He's also an actor, a director, a writer, a husband, a dad, and right now he's our guest. Oh, that's right. Please welcome the man of many things. Comedy Swiss Army knife, y'all. Here he is, Mike Berbiglia. Oh. Mike Berbiglia. Mike Berb he is, Mike Berbiglia. Oh, I think Will was just saying the other day, you know, we should get Mike Berbiglia on the show. Wait, you've been on my list for like three years.
他还是个演员、导演、编剧、丈夫、父亲，而现在他是我们的嘉宾。哦，对了。请欢迎这位身兼数职的奇才。喜剧界的瑞士军刀，各位！他就是，麦克·博比利亚。哦。麦克·博比利亚。麦克·博比——他来了，麦克·博比利亚。哦，我想威尔前几天刚说过，你知道的，我们应该请麦克·博比利亚上节目。等等，你在我的邀请名单上呆了大约三年了。
We have talked about getting Mike on the show and I, Mike, hi, Mike. Hey, I already had him. I'm really good, man. It's been a minute. It's been sense, it's been sense. We were in pop star together, I think. No, no, no, no, no, it's been, I've seen you since then. Oh, no, we did that benefit for Canada. You came in very kindly. Did that benefit? Talk about a guy who stood up in front of people during the pandemic, when you guys were all worried about when the government was trying to depopulate, I forget what they were trying to do, but they were trying to do something.
我们一直讨论要请麦克上节目，而且我，麦克，嗨，麦克。嘿，我已经请过他了。我真的很好，伙计。好久不见了。好久没见了，好久没见了。我们一起拍过《流行巨星》，我想。不，不，不，不，不，好久没见了，我从那以后见过你。哦，不对，我们为加拿大做过那个慈善义演。你非常热心地赶来了。做了那场义演？说到在疫情期间挺身而出面对观众的家伙，当时你们都在担心政府试图减少人口，我忘了他们当时试图干嘛，但他们确实想搞点什么。
The government had this crazy plan to get us all. And we, Mike kindly, we did this, this charity for this hospital in Canada, and he very kindly showed up and did a set virtually, which is so fucking hard. Oh, wait, so fucking hard. Oh wait, so you can. And I had such admiration for what you did. You were so funny and so fucking good, Mike, and doing it into a camera.
政府有个疯狂的计划要把我们一网打尽。然后，麦克很热心地，我们为加拿大的一家医院办了这场慈善演出，他非常热心地出现并在线上做了一场表演，这他妈太难了。哦，等等，太他妈难了。哦，等等，所以你可以。我对你的所作所为充满了敬佩。你太搞笑了，而且他妈的太棒了，麦克，而且是对着摄像头表演。
It was honestly. It was like via zoom or something. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, stand up. Via zoom. And all the people, thousands or hundreds and thousands of people in Toronto for this thing were watching him. And he's got to do it with no crowd in front of the camera.
老实说，真是太……就像通过Zoom或者别的什么。对，对。对，单口喜剧。通过Zoom。所有在多伦多参加这个活动的人，成千上万的人都在看他演出。而他必须在没有任何观众的情况下对着摄像头表演。
And I thought, man, that is first of all, you got to be really funny to pull that off. Thanks a lot, man. Yeah. It was fun. It was very kind of you. And then, well, the other thing about that gig ended up being a seminal thing for me, because Steve Martin also performed. Yes.
我想，天哪，首先，你必须极其搞笑才能搞定这个。太谢谢你了，伙计。不客气。这很有趣。你太客气了。然后，关于那场演出的另一件事，最终对我来说具有开创性的意义，因为史蒂夫·马丁也表演了。是的。
Well, Steve came and did a Q&A with me, which was also kind, yeah. And then I did a joke that he, so I had a joke that's in my new specialty old man in the pool and I say, I love pizza so much I get excited when I see the word plaza. That's a great joke. Because the word pizza is exciting. It has pizza in it. Each of the Z's is two slices. The A is a slice.
史蒂夫来了，跟我做了一个问答环节，这也非常热心，对。然后我讲了一个笑话，他——所以我有一个笑话，在我最新的专场《池畔老头》里，我说，我太喜欢披萨（pizza）了，以至于看到“广场”（plaza）这个词我都会兴奋。这真是一个绝妙的笑话。因为“pizza”这个词很让人兴奋。里面包含了“pizza”。每个“z”代表两片。字母“a”代表一片。
It's five slices in one word, which is a rarely used literary device I invented called Anamata Pizza. Now, the reason I bring this up is that Steve Martin was on the Zoom with us and he wrote me a side note and he goes, hey, I love that Anamata pizza joke and I immediately put it in my show and it's in the final show. It's because of him that I put it in.
一个词里有五片，这是一个很少使用的我发明的文学修辞手法，叫做“拟披萨声”（Anamata Pizza）。现在，我提起这个的原因是，史蒂夫·马丁和我们一起在Zoom上，他给我发了一条私信，他说，嘿，我喜欢那个“拟披萨声”的笑话，我立刻把它放进了我的演出里，它现在在最后的演出里。就是因为他，我才把它放进去的。
No way. Yeah, true story. Did you grow up loving Steve Martin? Were you a huge fan? Oh my. I mean, the great, the great, the giant. I mean, it's the, I mean, honestly, like born standing up is book. One of the best.
真的假的？对啊，千真万确。你从小就喜欢史蒂夫·马丁吗？你是他的超级粉丝吗？天哪。我的意思是，这位伟人，这位巨匠。我的意思是，真的，就像他的书《生而站立》（Born Standing Up）。绝对是最好的之一。
I read it. Yeah, one of the great books about comedy. And then when I was starting out on the road, striving around the country and listening to Steve Martin albums, I mean, that's, that's all I was listening to. Some, he was in the audience for Old Man and the pool. And when he is in the audience sometimes for my shows, I feel self-conscious because I'm looking at him going, I have stolen this all from you.
我看过。对，关于喜剧的伟大著作之一。然后当我刚开始在路上巡演时，开车周游全国，听着史蒂夫·马丁的专辑，我的意思是，那就是我当时听的全部内容。有时候，他会坐在《池畔老头》的观众席里。当他有时坐在我演出的观众席里时，我会感到很不自在，因为看着他，我在想：我这一切都是从你那儿偷来的。
Right. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Now Will, you know him a little bit. Why haven't you gotten him on the show yet? Well, we've talked about, I know Steve very little bit. And Sean does too, and he's very good, obviously, really close with Marty Short. And first of all, I thought, Sean,
对。对，对，对。现在，威尔，你对他有点了解。你为什么到现在还没请他上节目呢？好吧，我们聊过，我对史蒂夫只有一点点了解。西恩也了解一点，他显然很厉害，跟马蒂·肖特非常亲近。首先，我觉得，西恩，
when you said, Mike, I thought you said, did you grow up loving, I thought, did you grow up loving pizza like I did? But you were about to see that. That's the follow-up. But yeah, I feel the same way. I love Steve as well, and I read his book, like you guys, and was just blown away by it.
当你提到“麦克”时，我还以为你在说，你从小就喜欢……我还以为你想说你从小就跟我一样喜欢披萨呢。但你正要说这个。那是接下来的话。不过是的，我有同感。我也很喜欢史蒂夫，和你们一样，我读了他的书，简直惊为天人。
And just everything he says, and just, you know, he's, he's Steve Martin. What do you say, right? I mean, he's. Well, that he can write, he can write stand-up, he can write books, he can write specials, he can write music. He can write music. But also, what I love about him too is he has such a wider view. There are so many people we know who do, who do what we do.
他说的每一句话，而且，你知道的，他可是史蒂夫·马丁。你还能说什么呢，对吧？我的意思是，他就是。嗯，他能写，他能写单口喜剧，他能写书，他能写专场，他能写音乐。他能写音乐。但同时，我最喜欢他的一点是，他拥有如此广阔的视野。我们认识的很多人，他们都在做，都在做我们做的事。
Yeah. But have such a, who really kind of, that's what they are. They're a standup comic or they're an actor and that's what kind of what they do. And Steve has such a broader view of the world. You know, he collects art. He's interested in music. He does a lot. And he is truly a well-rounded person. I don't think there's enough for when you get him on the show. I know. I don't know. I don't know. I was. How do you say this for when you get him on the show? I don't. I don't know. I was just saying, I'm not gonna talk to Mike.
是的。但他们的眼光很局限，他们真正认准的，也就是那一套。他们是个单口喜剧演员，或者是个演员，这就是他们的全部工作。而史蒂夫对世界有着更广阔的视野。你知道的，他收藏艺术品。他对音乐感兴趣。他涉猎广泛。他真是一个全面发展的人。当你请他上节目时，这些都还不够聊的。我知道。我不知道。我不知道。我当时——你怎么能在请他上节目的时候说这些呢？我不会。我不会。我只是说，我不会跟麦克说话。
Mike is my big deal. Because of saying that, Mike. Mike appreciates him in the same way, because he really is looking at appreciates him. And so, and I think that Mike, a lot of your stand-up also is about, not just about, it is kind of like, you are a storyteller, I hate saying it. Oh God, I can't believe you said it.
麦克是我的大人物。因为说了这个，麦克。麦克对他的欣赏也是一样的，因为他确实在看着并欣赏他。所以，而且我觉得麦克，你的很多单口喜剧也是关于，不仅仅是关于，它有点像，你是个故事讲述者，我讨厌这么说。哦天哪，真不敢相信你把它说出来了。
No, I don't mind that word. You don't. Well, in this context, it's, it's filmmakers that are called. We have a tough time when filmmakers go as a storyteller. You know, I'm just storyteller. Yeah, yeah. Okay. I guess it's, but you mic, but you mic. That's what you do. Yeah. So, uh, and, and, and so what that, that that, it's not joke, joke, joke, joke, joke. It's you're, you're walking people through a situation. And in that situation are many funny things. Yes. Yeah, because I think, you know, what happened, what, what, it started out and when I was
不，我不介意这个词。你倒不介意。好吧，在这种语境下，电影制作人才会被这么叫。每当电影制作人自称是“故事讲述者”时，我们都会觉得很难受。你知道的，我只是个故事讲述者。对，对。好吧。我想是的，但是麦克，但是麦克。这就是你的风格。是的。所以，呃，而且，而且，所以那种，那种，它不是那种纯粹的笑话连珠炮。而是你带着大家经历一种处境。而那种处境中包含着很多有趣的事情。是的。是的，因为我觉得，你知道，事情是怎样的，它最初开始的时候，当我
in college, I was studying screenwriting and playwriting. And then I was doing stand up at a comedy club in Washington DC. And I was working the door, and I was kind of watching all these comedians come through. And then at a certain point, I kind of merged those two things, and I started telling stories, started telling stories on this American life, and on the Moth, and then I created what, you know,
在读大学时，我学的是编剧和戏剧创作。然后在华盛顿特区的一个喜剧俱乐部里说单口喜剧。我在门口当迎宾，看着各种各样的喜剧演员来来往往。后来在某个阶段，我把这两者结合在了一起，我开始讲故事，开始在《This American Life》和《The Moth》上讲故事，然后我创作了，你知道的，
I started, my first one was called Sleepwalk with me, one of these solo shows, and Nathan Lane presented it, and it really actually kind of changed my life, it's 2008. I love that. And what are you doing studying screenwriting at Georgetown? Isn't that supposed to be like the log capital of the world? Or is it? You know, it is, but in my class,
我开始了，我的第一个作品叫《与我梦游》（Sleepwalk with Me），是一部单人喜剧秀，南森·连恩担任了制作人，这真的可以说是改变了我的人生，那是2008年。我太喜欢那个了。你在乔治城学编剧时都在干嘛？那不是号称全美录取率最低的学校之一吗？还是说？你知道的，确实是，但在我的班上，
in my screenwriting class, it was Joan and Nolan. Oh, sure. That went on to write the prestige and momentum and all kinds of amazing stuff. I'm gonna look those up. I'm gonna look those up. Jordan Nardino, Brendan O'Brien wrote neighbors, like a lot of, a lot of writers who ended up in this,
在我的编剧班里，有乔恩和诺兰。哦，当然。后来他们去写了《致命魔术》（The Prestige）、《记忆碎片》（Memento）以及各种各样惊艳的作品。我得去查查他们。我得去查查他们。乔丹·纳迪诺（Jordan Nardino）、布伦丹·奥布赖恩（Brendan O'Brien）写了《邻居大战》（Neighbors），还有好多好多编剧，他们最后都走上了这条路，
it was his class, this top by this guy named John Glab. When do you go, JB, you've offended a lot of great writers. I'm just saying, it's sort of a backhand compliment. I mean, that place is a very difficult school to get accepted to. You also have a lot of agree. Yes, exactly. I also have a lot of agree.
那是这个班，由一个叫约翰·格拉布（John Glab）的人教的。你什么时候去，杰比，你得罪了不少优秀的编剧。我只是说，这算是一种反讽式的赞美。我的意思是，那个地方是一所极难考进去的学校。你也有很多同感。是的，没错。我也有很多同感。
I picked up a lot of agree, but no, I agree with you. Storytelling is one of those things where when you say I'm going to tell a story, people, oh God. But I think the key to it is it just has to be funny all the way through. Yeah, I love story. I think it's a very unique skill because and there are a lot of different kinds of comics in some who just are like, we know them. Some are just like absolute just just a joke, just a line, just a turn of
我表示赞同的地方很多，但说真的，我同意你的看法。讲故事就是那种只要你说“我要讲个故事”，人们就会“哦天哪”的东西。但我认为其中的关键在于，整个过程必须始终保持有趣。是的，我很喜欢故事。我认为这是一种非常独特的技能，因为有些喜剧演员，我们都认识他们，有些纯粹就是——纯粹靠笑话、靠金句、靠某一种措辞
phrase or whatever and that's their thing. But to be able to tell a story and hold people through a story and be kind of funny the whole way and then pay it off, it's really satisfying as a as an audience member. Now let me ask you this. Because it's tough to do. It is tough. What would you say since you've had these great one-man shows, what would be the difference considering your stand-up style is much like what one would consider maybe a one-man show would be like?
或者诸如此类的东西撑场面，那就是他们的风格。但能够讲好一个故事，用故事吸引住大家，在整个过程中一直保持幽默，最后再抖出包袱，作为观众，这种感觉真的非常过瘾。现在我问你这个。因为这很难做到。确实很难。鉴于你创作了这些精彩的独幕剧，你觉得你的单口喜剧风格很像人们心目中的独幕剧，你认为你的单人秀和你在单口喜剧专场中的写作之间，最主要的区别是什么？
What would you characterize the major differences between your one-man shows and the work that you do, the writing that you do for a stand-up set? I just think like a typical stand-up is basically built on the premise of, you have a series of set-up, punch line, set-up, punch line, set-up, punch line. My sort of like what I've learned through the years is those jokes can be part of a five-minute story.
你会怎么形容？我只是觉得，典型的单口喜剧基本上是建立在这样的前提之上的：你有一系列“铺垫-包袱”、“铺垫-包袱”、“铺垫-包袱”的结构。而我通过这些年学到的是，那些笑话可以成为一个五分钟故事的一部分。
And if you have 10 a five-minute story. And if you have 10, five-minute stories that add up to a single story, that's really the goal of all my shows. And if there can be an emotional payoff at the end of it, like the last show I did on Netflix was called The New One. It was all about how all the reasons why... That's a great title. I think on the second.
如果你有十个这样的五分钟故事。如果你有十个五分钟的故事，它们组合成一个完整的故事，这其实就是我所有节目的目标。如果能在结尾处带来情感上的爆发，比如我在网飞（Netflix）上做的最后一个节目叫《新来的》（The New One）。它讲的全都是关于所有……这名字真棒。我想在第二部里。
It's all about how I never wanted to have a child. And then essentially how I had a child and why I was right. And then ultimately why I was wrong. You know, and that's the emotional turn of it. But I mean, I've always just felt like, it's kind of a matter of like, what do you want to pack into your 90 minutes? It's like, that's why I love movies.
它讲的全都是我过去多么不想生孩子。然后基本上是讲我是怎么有了孩子，为什么我一开始觉得自己是对的。最后又是为什么我其实是错的。你知道的，这就是情感上的转折。不过我的意思是，我一直觉得，这有点像你想在你的90分钟里塞进什么内容？这就是为什么我喜欢电影。
Like I love movies because- One of those big, one of those big tens of caramel corn, you know, a Star Wars movie. Yeah. And maybe, sorry, I'm sorry. I thought you said, would this show want to pack into 90 minutes? It's, it's something like a big tens, it's like a big tin and it's caramel corn. Yeah. By the way, relate to Sean going home early from the party.
就像我喜欢电影因为——就像那一桶桶焦糖爆米花，你知道的，比如《星球大战》电影。对，也许，对不起，对不起。我以为你刚才说，这个节目想在90分钟里塞进什么？这就像一个大桶，里面装满了焦糖爆米花。对。顺便说一句，这和西恩早早从派对上溜回家有关。
Yeah. You do. Oh my relate to Sean going home early from the party. Yeah. You do. Yeah. Oh my god. Are you kidding? But you want to stuck around, Mike. Mike, you want to suck around your gear. But, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, that are different than going to see you do a set
对。你确实。哦，这和西恩早早从派对上溜回家有关。对。你确实。对。哦天哪。你在开玩笑吗？但你想留下来，麦克。麦克，你想留下来……（被打断）与你去看单口喜剧俱乐部里那种单口表演是不同的。你的单人秀和单口喜剧专场之间到底有什么区别？所以当我在俱乐部演出时，我现在正带着我的下一个新秀进行巡演，名字叫《请停下这趟过山车》（Please Stop the Ride），大概会去25个城市，那将是纯正的单口喜剧。
at a comedy place doing a stand-up. What is the difference between your one-man show and doing a stand-up special? So when I do clubs, I'm going out on tour right now with my next show, which is called Please Stop the Ride, and it's like 25 cities, and that'll be stand up.
它将是我日后变成单人秀的早期阶段，纯粹是单口。那是一堆笑话。那是一堆故事。它是自由形式的。有即兴发挥。什么都可能发生。而那些演出本身也充满乐趣。
It'll be the early stages of what become my one person shows are stand up. It's like a bunch of jokes. It's a bunch of stories. It's free form. There's improv. Anything can happen. And those shows are fun in their own way.
然后到了某个阶段，你知道的，一切就都定型了。一切都定型了。是的。然后到了某个阶段，当我2008年刚开始做这些演出，演《与我梦游》的时候，我开始和导演塞斯·巴里什（Seth Barish）合作。所以这些年来，我们会一起构建，他会说，你知道吗，
And then at a certain point, like, you know, it's all over. It's all over. Yeah. And then at a certain point, like, when I first started out with these shows in 2008, with Sleepwalk with me, I started working with this director Seth Barish. And so over the years, like, we'll construct, we'll go, you know, he'll go, you know, what
根据你说的故事，我得到的理解是这样的。而我会说，哦，好吧，我本来不是那个意思。我本来是这个意思，然后我会重写。这就经历了一轮又一轮的修改，直到我真正能够传达出我脑海里原本想要表达的那个故事。而那个《与我梦游》的创作灵感其实是受到了……告诉这些家伙。我可是做过功课的。非常、非常、非常，告诉这些，告诉这些家伙那到底是怎么回事，是的，那是个字面意义上的标题。
I get from what you're saying as a story is this. And I'll go, oh, okay, I wasn't intending that. I was intending this and I'll rewrite it. And it's kind of like a series of revisions and revisions revisions until I'm actually conveying the story that I'm intending in what's in my head basically. And that one sleepwalking with me was was motivated birth by prompted by tell these fellas. I've done my research there. Very, very, very, tell these, tell these fellas what that, what that, yeah, that's a literal title.
所以，《与我梦游》是基于我身上发生的一个真实故事改编的，那就是我患有非常严重的梦游症，医学上叫快速眼动睡眠行为障碍。我想问问你这个。所以，所以事情是多年前开始的，我当时20多岁。我和当时的初恋女友同居。我开始做噩梦，而且是反复做同一个梦。我们卧室里有一只盘旋的、像胡狼一样的昆虫，
So, Sleepwalk with me is based on a story that happened to me, which is that I have a very serious sleepwalk in a sort of called REM sleep behavior disorder. I want to ask you about that. And so, and so it started out years ago, I was in my 20s. I was living with my girlfriend at the time. I started having a recurring dream. There was a hovering insect like Jackal in our bedroom
我跳上床，摆出一个空手道姿势，而我的女友艾比会说，你会，你会空手道吗？不，不，我小时候在书展上买过书，但我从来没练过。好吧，但我跳上床上说，房间里有只胡狼，她说，没有胡狼。
and I jumped on the bed and I strike a karate pose and my girlfriend, Abby, would go, did you know, did you know karate? No, no, I had the books for book fair when I was a kid, but I never took it. Okay, but I jump on the bed and I said, there's a jackal in the room and she goes, there's no jackal.
我说，好吧，然后我就睡觉了。接着情况越来越严重。有一次我在华盛顿州的瓦拉瓦拉（Walla Walla）出差，那在华盛顿州东部。一切发生的地方。我当时住在华盛顿州瓦拉瓦拉的速8酒店（La Quinta Inn）。没错。
I go, okay, and I go to bed. And then it got increasingly worse. And I had this incident in, I was in Walla Walla Washington, which is an Eastern Washington. Where it all happened. And I was at La Quinta Inn. Sure.
大概就是那个麻烦。我当时住在速8酒店。没错。然后……大概就是那个麻烦。我做了一个梦，梦见有一枚巡航导弹正朝我的房间飞来。里面全都是军事人员。我从床上跳起来，说，计划是什么？他们说……这就是计划。
And that's about a trouble. And I was at Lakinta Inn. Sure. And... That's about a trouble. And I had a dream that there was a guided missile headed towards my room. And there's all these military personnel. I jump out of bed, I say, what's the plan? And they say... It's a plan.
对，对，对。我在梦里非常有行动力。你当时摆出那个姿势了吗？你摆出那个姿势了吗？还在摆？我当时正摆着姿势。我当时在摆姿势？你当时摆出那个姿势了吗？还在摆？我当时在摆姿势。我当时正摆着姿势，对，对。真他妈的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm very action oriented in my dreams. Were you in the pose? Were you in the pose? Still? I was in the pose. I'm in the pose? Were you in the pose? Still? I was in the pose. I'm in the pose, yeah, yeah. Fuck it.
然后他们说，然后他们说，我们注意到，导弹的坐标已经锁定你了。没错。我后来被诊断出患有这种病，叫做快速眼动睡眠行为障碍，患者会在睡眠中把梦境演绎出来。所以我决定在梦里，
And they say, and they say, it's come to our attention, the missile coordinates are set on you. Right. And I was later diagnosed with this thing, REM sleep behavior disorder, where people act out their dreams. And so I decide in my dream,
事实证明在我的现实生活中也是如此——跳出窗外，以便在窗外引爆，从而拯救整个排的战友。天哪。你对那个梦记得这么清楚吗？是的，我记得。我literally（真的），说出来挺搞笑的，西恩，因为我当晚就把这一切都写下来了。
and as it turns out in my life, to jump out my window, so as to detonate outside the window for the sake of the platoon. Oh my God. And do you remember the dream that vividly? I do, yeah. I literally, it's funny to just say that, Sean, because I wrote it down that night.
我还拍了照片。你知道的，我有时会在Instagram上发一些，比如我跳窗时的实景，这里有两个重要的细节。第一，我在二楼。第二，窗户是关着的，当时正值一月。所以我像绿巨人一样，像不可思议的绿巨人一样，直接撞破了二楼的窗户跳了出去。好吧，这在某种程度上能帮到你的处境吗？
I took photos of it. You know, I post some of my Instagrams sometimes, like the actual, I jumped, there's two important details. One, I was on the second floor. Two, the window was closed, it was January. So I jumped through a second story window like the Hulk, like the Incredible Hulk. Yeah. Now, this was going to help your situation in what way though?
你刚才说为了引爆自己。对，这是一个非常棒的问题，杰森。为了在窗外引爆自己来拯救全排。但导弹不是正在飞过来吗？对啊，没错。是的，但它正飞过来。但它锁定了我。它锁定了我，老兄。哦，哦，我明白了。我明白了。我明白了。我明白了。是的。好吧。所以我跳出了窗户。是的。而这些人都是你曾和他们一起经历过生死之交的战友，所以你想拯救，对吧？你想拯救，你想拯救，显然你们在那里经历了很多。
You said to detonate yourself. Yeah, it's a very great question, Jason. It's a detonate outside the window for the sake of the platoon. But the missile was incoming. Yes, indeed. Yeah, but it was coming. But it was on me. It was on him, dude. Oh, oh, got you. Got you. Got you. Got you. Yeah. Okay. So I jump through the window. Yeah. And these are these are guys that you've been in the shit with. So you're, you want to save, right? This is you want to save, you want to save, obviously, you guys have been through a lot there.
你们就像兄弟一样。对，我们就像，我们是一支兄弟连，在华盛顿州瓦拉瓦拉。我们懂的。我们马上回来。感谢Liquid IV对《SmartLess》的大力支持。新年到了，2024年到了。我正试图为新的一年寻找一个全新的自己。
You're like brothers. Yeah, we're like, we're a band of brothers and Wala Wala Wash, you're 10. We got you. We'll be right back. Our thanks to Liquid IV for supporting SmartLas. So it's New Year, it's 2024. I'm trying to figure out the new me for the new year.
我知道你在想什么，我也知道你在说什么。西恩，你不需要一个全新的自己，做你自己就好。但我需要一个全新的自己。所以也许你是对的，也许我不需要为新的一年重塑自我，也许我只需要用Liquid IV为自己重新补充水分，它含有领先运动饮料3倍的电解质，外加8种日常健康所需的维生素和营养素，
I know what you're thinking, I know what you're saying. Sean, you don't need a new you, just be you. But I need a new me. So maybe you're right, maybe I don't reinvent myself for the new year, maybe just rehydrate myself with liquid IV, with three times the electrolytes of the leading sports drink, plus eight vitamins and nutrients for everyday wellness,
Liquid IV的水合补水速度比单独喝水快两倍。所有这一切都浓缩在一个不含糖的便携条里，让你感觉自己像一个水分充足、准备好迎接2024年的崭新自我。你知道的，在健身房锻炼之后，或者更重要的是，在录完像《Smartless》这样的播客之后，我浑身是汗，我需要补充水分，我需要恢复活力，所以我把一支Liquid IV倒进水里，
liquid IV hydrates two times faster than water alone. All in a single sugar-free stick, so you can feel like a hydrated new you ready to take on 2024. You know, after the gym or more importantly, after a podcast like Smartless, I just kind of am sweating, I need to replenish, I need to rejuvenate, so I pop a liquid IV into some water,
喝起来味道好极了。而且确实很管用。说真的，Liquid IV彻底改变了补水游戏规则，只需一小条就能将16盎司的水变成补水能量站。此外，它还是非转基因的，制作过程中不含麸质、乳制品或大豆，是你打造更健康自体的终极补水伴侣。
and it tastes delicious. And it does the trick. Seriously, liquid IV is a hydration game changer with a single-stick transforming 16 ounces of water into a hydration powerhouse. Plus, it's non-GMO and crafted without gluten, dairy, or soy, the ultimate hydration companion for a healthier you.
在新的一年里为自己重新补充水分吧。赶紧在全国Costco大批量购买你的Liquid IV水合倍增无糖版，或者登录liquidiv.com购买首单即可享受8折优惠，结账时使用代码Smartless。只要在今天购买优质补水产品，首单即可享受8折优惠。但你必须在liquidiv.com结账时使用我们的优惠码Smartless。本节目由BetterHelp赞助播出。你知道的，每个人都在谈论新年新气象，对吧？
Rehydrate yourself for the new year. Grab your liquid IV hydration multiplier sugar-free in bulk nationwide at Costco or get 20% off your first order when you go to liquidiv.com and use code Smartless to check out that's 20% off your first order when you shop better hydration today. But you gotta use our promo code Smartless at liquidiv.com. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So you know, everybody's talking about a new year, new you, right?
然后这反而会让你对自我感觉变差。就像，为什么每个人都觉得我需要变成一个全新的我？好吧，你不需要。也许你只需要在现有的基础上做得更好一点，挑战自己成为一个更好的自己，那个本就已经存在、只需稍加挑战就能变得更好的自己。也许你终于整理好了一个房间，想要挑战下一个，或者你每天都在吃补充剂，现在你甚至想正经吃个早餐
And then it kind of makes you feel bad about yourself. It's like, why does everybody think I need to be a new me, right? Well, you don't. Maybe you just need to improve on what's already there and kind of challenge yourself to be in even better you, that's already there and kind of challenge yourself to be an even better you that's already you. Maybe you finally organized one part of your space and you want to tackle another, or maybe you're taking your supplements every morning and now you want to actually eat breakfast,
了。还记得早餐吗？心理咨询能帮你找到内心的力量，让你摆脱极端的新年决心，做出真正能够坚持下去的改变。如你所知，我一直都在谈论心理咨询。我总是去做心理咨询。我爱死它了。它总是能让你感觉更好。
too. Remember breakfast? Therapy helps you find your strength so you can ditch the extreme resolutions and make changes that really stick. As you know, I always talk about therapy. I always go to therapy. I love it. I always make you feel better.
总能帮你想通心中的疙瘩。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线进行，旨在提供便捷、灵活且适合你日程安排的服务。只需填写一份简单的问卷，就能与有执照的心理咨询师进行匹配，并且可以随时免费更换咨询师。
Always helps to work out the kinks. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with the licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge.
庆祝你已经取得的进步。今天就访问betterhelp.com斜杠smartness，首个月即可享受9折优惠。网址是BetterHelp-HELP.com斜杠smartless。感谢我们的新赞助商Car Shield对本节目的支持。开车出行几乎是一种生活方式，但你最不希望看到的就是车子抛锚在路边。如果你是数百万驾驶着过保车辆的美国车司机之一，你很可能会
Celebrate the progress you've already made. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartness today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp-HELP.com-slash-smartless. Thank you to one of our new sponsors, Car Shield, for supporting the show. Traveling by car is practically a way of life, but the last thing you want is to get stuck on the side of the road. If you're one of millions of Americans driving an out-of-war and tea vehicle, you're liable
为数千美元的高昂维修费用买单，哪怕你的车才开三年。Car Shield的保护计划起价约为每月100美元，提供不同等级的保障，并且大多数计划都包含全国范围的道路救援、免费拖车以及租车服务，不收取额外费用。Car Shield提供的维修保障涵盖多达5000个零件，比以往任何时候都多。最棒的是，完全不用处理繁琐的文件或头疼的流程。
to be on the hook for thousands of dollars in costly repairs, even if your car is only three years old. With protection plans starting at around $100 a month, Car Shield offers varying levels of coverage, and most plans include coast to coast roadside assistance, courtesy towing, and car rental options at no extra cost. Car Shield offers repair coverage for up to 5,000 parts more parts than ever before. And here's the beauty, no dealing with paperwork or headaches.
你挑选修理厂，剩下的交给Car Shield。此外，他们还有超赞的保价承诺。无论你索赔多少次，你的费率都不会变。今年，有了Car Shield，再也不用为昂贵的汽车维修烦恼了。访问我们的网址carshield.com斜杠smartless，今天即可节省20%。再次强调，网址是carshield.com斜杠smartless，立省20%。访问carshield.com斜杠smartless，今天就锁定你的价格。现在让我们回到节目中。
You pick the mechanic and car shield takes care of the rest. Plus, they've got this sweet price lock guarantee. Your rate stays put no matter how many claims you file. This year, avoid the hassle of costly car repairs with car shield. Visit our URL at carshield.com slash smartless and save 20% today. Again, that's carshield.com slash smartless to save 20%. Visit carshield.com slash smartless to lock in your price today. And now back to the show.
所以你决定把攻击目标从任何和你同床共枕的人以及其他人身上转移开，对吧。然后你打算，对吧。所以你直接降落在停车场了？我其实降落在了汽车旅馆的前草坪上。我摔了一跤，然后爬起来继续跑。天哪。我一边跑一边渐渐意识到，我穿着内衣浑身是血地站在华盛顿州瓦拉瓦拉速8酒店的前草坪上。我
So you decided to move the target away from whoever you were sleeping with and the other people are, yeah. And you were going to, yeah. So you land in the parking lot? I land actually on the front lawn of the motel. I take a fall and I get up and I keep running. Oh my God. And I'm running and I'm slowly realizing I'm on the front lawn of Lakinta Inn in Wala Wala Washington in my underwear bleeding. And I'm
心想，哦不。但在那一刻，我庆幸自己没有被导弹击中。还没。当然。我记得那个。对，没错。我当时觉得那才叫灾难呢。至少我还在局里。等等，摔那一跤居然没把你摔醒？摔跤？摔那一跤算是把我摔醒了。等等，撞碎玻璃窗居然没把你弄醒？或者那么大一道伤口？没有，没有。
like, oh no. But in that moment, I was relieved that I hadn't been hit by the missile. Yet. Sure. I remember that. Yeah, exactly. I thought that would have been a disaster. At least I'm still in the game. Wait, so the fall didn't wake you up. Fall? The fall sort of woke me up. Well, hang on, the going through the glass window didn't wake you up. Or the big gash. No, no.
没有，我走到前台说，嗨。我在流血。我只穿着内衣。我说，嘿，我住在这个旅馆里。我发生了一起事故，我不小心从——顺便说一句，多年后，我收到了前台这位老兄发的一封电子邮件，他说，嘿，我就是那个人。不，哦天哪。
No, I went to the front desk and I said hi. I'm bleeding. I'm in my underwear. And I go, hey, I'm staying at the motel. I had an incident wherein I jumped through my, by the way, years later, I got an email from this guy at the front desk saying, hey, I was the guy. No, oh my god.
我当时就在那个旅馆。我住在这儿，从窗户跳出去了。我需要一把备用钥匙。我在流血。我在流血。我在流血。我在流血。我得看医生，我需要一把备用钥匙。我在流血。我在流血。我得看医生，我需要一把备用钥匙。他说，好吧，然后他说，于是我自己开车去了医院，我，我，
I was at the motel. I'm staying here, jumped through my window. I'm gonna need a second key. I'm bleeding. I'm bleeding. I'm bleeding. I'm bleeding. I need to see a doctor, need a second key. I'm bleeding. I'm bleeding. I need to see a doctor, need a second key. And he goes, all right, and he goes, and so I drove myself to the hospital and I, I,
我挂了号，你知道的，我去了，我得在那儿解释，把发生了什么解释了整整三遍。护士、前台、医生，我就是，我就是绿巨人。我就是绿巨人。我就是绿巨人，你知道的，有个家伙说，不，你是布鲁斯·班纳，我心想，好吧，算你狠。所以你当时还以为自己在做梦？不，不，不，到了这个时候，不，不，到了这个时候，
I checked myself, you know, I went to the, I had to explain there, it's three times what happened. The nurse, the receptionist of the doctor, I'm the, I'm the Hulk. I'm the Hulk. I'm the Hulk, you know, one guy was like, no, your Bruce Banner, I was like, point taking care. So you still think you're dreaming? No, no, no, at this point, no, no, at this point,
我已经有点意识了。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不利地从我腿里取出了玻璃。真的是从我腿里取出了玻璃。那块玻璃距离我的股动脉只有一厘米。如果它刺破了那里，我就会在前草坪上流血过多而死。然后我飞回了纽约，做了我看到那只……你知道的，胡狼和其他东西时本该做的事。
I'm kind of aware. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no It took glass out of my legs. Literally took glass out of my legs. The glass was about a centimeter from my femoral artery. And if it had struck there, I would have just bled out on the front lawn and died. And then I flew back to New York and I did what I should have done when I saw the, you know, jackal and everything.
我有点意识到了。不，不，不……它从我腿里取出了玻璃。真的从我腿里取出了玻璃。那块玻璃距离我的股动脉只有大约一厘米。如果它刺中那里，我就会在前院流血过多而死。然后我飞回了纽约，做了当我看到那只胡狼以及一切时本该做的事。
I went to a doctor's specializes in sleep disorders and I was diagnosed with this serious thing. Fuck. But that story, so that story in the context of my first solo show, which was called Sleepwalk with me, and it became a independent film and everything, and it was- You directed. Then I directed, and, uh, thanks. And, uh, it was, I mean, thematically, and in real life, truthfully, it really was.
我去看了一位专门研究睡眠障碍的医生，我被诊断出患有一种很严重的病。妈的。但那个故事，也就是我的第一部单人脱口秀《与我梦游》背景中的那个故事，后来它拍成了独立电影之类的，那是——你导演的。后来我导演了，然后，呃，谢谢。然后，呃，我是说，从主题上来看，在现实生活中，说实话，确实是这样的。
It was, it's really about denial and about being in denial of the fact that I have this sleep disorder and not dealing with it. You still have it and suffer from it and what do you do? And so I, I was diagnosed with REM sleep behavior disorder. I was prescribed medication and I still had sleep walking issues and I said to my doctor, like, hey, I still have this sometimes.
这确实、真的关乎否认，关乎不愿承认我有这种睡眠障碍，也不去处理它。你依然有这个毛病，深受其苦，那你怎么办呢？所以，我被诊断出患有快速眼动睡眠行为障碍。医生给我开了药，但我仍然有梦游的问题，我对医生说，嘿，我有时还是会有这种情况。
And she goes, well, one thing you could do is you could sleep in a sleeping bag up to your neck and you could wear mittens so you can't open the sleeping bag. And so I did that for a period of time. I don't really do that as much as I want. Until summer. Yeah, probably dropped a lot of waterways in there. Yep. But, wow. So she said that, she really do that as much as I do. Until summer. Yeah, probably dropped a lot of waterway in there.
她说，好吧，你可以做的一件事是，钻进一个直到脖子的睡袋里，然后戴上手套，这样你就拉不开睡袋了。所以我这样做了好一段时间。其实我并没有像我想的那样经常这么做。直到夏天。是的，大概在里面积攒了不少水流吧。没错。但是，哇哦。所以她这么说了，她真的不像我那样经常这样做。直到夏天。是的，大概在里面积攒了不少水流吧。
But, uh, wow. So she said that, she said do that. And then that worked for a little while. And then, and then what? Then just meth, just fucking, I'm not sleeping ever again. No, no, that's, I've been up for two years. Strap you down, right? I've been up for two years.
但是，呃，哇哦。所以她说了那个，她让我那么做。然后那样管用了一会儿。然后，然后呢？然后就直接嗑冰毒呗，操，我再也不睡觉了。不，不，那是，我已经两年没睡了。把你绑起来，对吧？我已经两年没睡了。
I've been up for two years and fucking, I wanna fucking beat this thing. Hey, first of all, Mike, I just wanna go back real quick. How they, how they get your coordinates. That's a great question. I mean, we never think about that. I think about this all the time. I actually didn't, I don't watch shocking movies.
我已经两年没睡了，操，我想把这毛病给治好。嘿，首先，迈克，我只想快速倒回一下。他们，他们是怎么掌握你的坐标的？这是个好问题。我是说，我们从没想过这一点。我一直在想这件事。其实我没有，我不看惊悚电影。
I don't watch, you know, things late at night because I worry that it's gonna affect my dreams. Of course, yeah. But that day, it's not even like I watched anything shocking. I was just driving through like the cascade mountains. This has appeared in my life in my 20s where I was performing at colleges. I was performing in like gymnasiums and cafeterias.
我深夜不看，你知道，那些内容，因为我担心那会影响我的梦。当然，是的。但那天，甚至都不是因为我看了什么惊悚的东西。我只是开车穿过喀斯喀特山脉。这事在我二十多岁时出现在我的生活中，当时我在大学里演出。我在体育馆和自助餐厅里演出。
It was like a really, it was, it was, it was in the grind. And I was just listening to a, like an NPR report on the radio about like missile defense. And, and, and, and, and, of course, that's what invaded my dream. So, so can you take a nap and, and, and, and will this happen if you take a nap? And now how do you sleep? And it's, do you sleep rest like you feel rested? I, I sleep a lot better. People, I, I'm one of those people
那种感觉就像真的，那种状态，就在那种打拼之中。我当时只是在收音机里听一个关于导弹防御的NPR（美国国家公共电台）报道。然后，然后，然后，然后，当然，这就侵入了我的梦。所以，所以你能小睡一会儿吗，而且，而且，如果你小睡的话会发生这种事吗？现在你是怎么睡觉的？还有，你睡得好吗？你感觉解乏吗？我睡得好多了。人们，我，我是那种人——
where I have the thing and all my friends know I have the sleep walking thing and when they have an issue sleeping, they call me like I'm a doctor and of course I'm not. And so I always recommend this book that was written years ago called The Promise of Sleep. And it's a lot of it's like sleep hygiene stuff. Like my sleep is better because like a few hours before bed,
我有这个毛病，我所有的朋友都知道我有梦游的毛病，当他们有睡眠问题时，他们就会打电话给我，就像我是个医生一样，而我当然不是。所以我总是推荐一本多年前写的书，叫《睡眠的承诺》（The Promise of Sleep）。里面有很多内容是关于睡眠卫生的。比如我的睡眠变好了，因为在睡前几个小时，
I shut off my phone, I stopped watching the news, whatever it is. And I sort of like, I think about landing, one way to look at is like landing into sleep as opposed to crashing into sleep. But honestly, in a real practical way, is the medication that that doctor prescribed you sufficient adequate? There've been no more episodes.
我关掉手机，我不再看新闻，无论什么内容都行。我有点像，我觉得可以把入睡看作是降落到睡眠中，而不是一头撞进睡眠中。但老实说，从非常实际的层面来看，那位医生给你开的药足够吗？没有再发作过吗？
Do you not worry about going to sleep that you're going to start walking around and do stuff like this? Or murder someone. Yeah. Yeah, no, that's definitely a concern. And I monitor it very, very closely. And I don't even want to show this. I don't want to take the drug is I don't wanna take the drug, you know,
你去睡觉时，不担心自己会开始到处溜达、做这种事吗？或者谋杀某人。对。对，不，那绝对是一个隐患。我非常、非常密切地监控着它。我甚至都不想展示这个。我不想吃这种药，因为我不想吃这种药，你知道，
like a few, I have to, like a few years, like recently I actually looked up the side effects of the, it's clonipin, you know, it's clonipin. Oh yeah, I've taken it. It's the drug I take, yeah. And it was like the side, you know, it was just, recently it was like the side effects I looked in, it was just like, it was like depression, effects I looked at, it was like depression,
就像几个，我必须，就像几年，最近我其实查了一下它的副作用，这是氯硝西泮（Clonazepam），你知道的，这是氯硝西泮。哦，对，我吃过。这是我吃的药，对。然后上面写着副作用，你知道，就在最近，我查了副作用，上面写着，就像是，就像是抑郁症，副作用我查了，上面写着是抑郁症，
poor motor skills and something else. And I was like, oh, I thought that was my personality. Oh, yeah, Sean, I think you're taking too much, Sean. Yeah, exactly. But boy, but I get, what would, I mean, I would probably, I would have to, I'd be so worried about falling asleep that I'd never would be able to fall asleep. And I wouldn't want to take that medication. I probably would like strap myself down, but then you wouldn't be able to roll over. So I'd probably like devise some
运动技能差以及其他一些毛病。当时我就想，哦，我还以为那是我的性格呢。哦，对，肖恩，我觉得你吃得太多了，肖恩。对，没错。但是天哪，但我懂，如果，我是说我可能会，我可能会太担心自己睡着而永远无法入睡。而且我不会想吃那种药。我可能会把自己绑起来，但那样你就无法翻身了。所以我可能会设计某种——
sort of box over my bed. I'd like build a box, like a, a cage to sleep in, something like that. And I talk about that more. I'm talking about the cage. a cage to sleep in something like that. And I talk about that more and talk about the cage. Yeah. There's a period of time where my wife Jenny is, of course, had a deal with this for many, many years. And the I know Jenny Jenny comes. So many reasons Jenny walks in the room.
在我的床上弄个那种盒子。我会造一个盒子，像个睡觉用的笼子，诸如此类。我稍后会多聊聊这个。我正在聊那个笼子。一个睡觉用的笼子，诸如此类。我稍后会多聊聊这个，聊聊那个笼子。是的。有一段时间，我的妻子珍妮，当然，她多年来不得不应付这件事。我知道珍妮，珍妮来了。有多少原因导致珍妮走进房间。
She's like missing an eye. She's got like yeah, walking on. She's wearing a full helmet. She and I listen to the podcast all the time. She's going to be devastated that this is her mention in the podcast. No, no, no, no, she's a poet. She's a poet in her own right. Yeah, how did you meet Jenny?
她看起来像是少了一只眼睛。她就像是，没错，走过来。她戴着一顶全盔。她和我经常听这个播客。她要是知道这是她在播客里被提及，肯定会崩溃的。不，不，不，不，她是个诗人。她本身就是个诗人。是的，你是怎么认识珍妮的？
I met Jenny in St. Louis. He has strangled her once, a midnight in St. Louis by the bus station. Okay, settle down, settle down, settle down. Yeah. No, we met in St. Louis many years ago and yeah, I, you know, it was one of those things that was, for me, it was, you know, it was love at first sight. Like, we were both on work, you know, on work trips and I just fell in love with their immediately and I'm in love with her this very day.
我是在圣路易斯认识珍妮的。他在圣路易斯的公交车站附近，在一个半夜勒过她一次。好了，消消气，消消气，消消气！对。不，我们多年前在圣路易斯认识的，是的，我，你知道，那是那种对我和我来说一见钟情的事。就像，我们当时都在出差，你知道，在出差途中，我立刻就爱上了她，直到今天我依然爱着她。
I was, you know, it was a great thing that I loved from your Mac and Ro episode recently, is he said this thing about he and his wife, which is that they let each other be who they are. And I was like, oh, that's such a beautiful sentiment. I thought, I said to Jenny, I go, I think of us that way. And she's a poet and I'm a comedian. And those are two people who don't know how heating
我，你知道，我最近从你们的马克·马龙（Marc Maron）那期节目里听到最棒的一点是，他说了一件关于他和妻子的事情，那就是他们让彼此做自己。当时我就想，哦，这真是太美好的情感了。我想，我对珍妮说，我说，我觉得我们也是这样的。她是个诗人，而我是一个喜剧演员。我们俩都是那种不懂供暖
and electricity work. Yeah. Yeah. I like that. I like that. He said that too and I was thinking about it too. Right. I will.
和电力是怎么运作的人。对。对。我喜欢这个。我也喜欢他说的那番话，我当时也在思考。没错。我会的。
You guys would agree Jason for sure Amanda lets you be who she is. And I think that that's one of the great things that makes it work for you guys. Oh, my. of the great things that makes it work for you guys. Mike. Now, Mike, you've got a podcast to your own call working it out. Working out. What are it? So it's an exercise. It's just at the gym. Well, similar. Just you just interviewing trainers and the treadmill. Yeah. The similar to to smartless working it out was a pandemic baby because I couldn't perform as a standup in front of audiences. And so I was like, so I started asking my friends,
你们一定会同意的，杰森，肯定的，阿曼达让你做你自己。我认为那是让你们俩走到一起并维系下去的伟大之处之一。哦，天哪。让你们俩走到一起的伟大之处之一。迈克。现在，迈克，你自己有一个播客叫《解决问题》（Working It Out）。《解决问题》。那是做什么的？所以它是一个锻炼。只是在健身房吗？嗯，差不多。就是你采访教练然后跑步？对。和《聪明人》（SmartLess）类似，《解决问题》是一个疫情期间的产物，因为我无法在观众面前进行单口喜剧表演。所以我想，我开始邀请我的朋友们，
you know, John Malaney and Bill Hader and Conan O'Brien, different people to work out jokes live on the show. And so now we're 115 episodes in and it's like a big part of my life. Like I just love doing it. That's great. All right. Yeah.
你知道，约翰·木兰尼（John Mulaney）、比尔·哈德（Bill Hader）、柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）以及不同的人，在节目中现场打磨笑话。所以现在我们已经播了115期了，这成了我生活中的很大一部分。我就是喜欢做这个。那太棒了。好吧。对。
It's the best. What's one of your earliest jokes that you wrote and that's tried and true always works? From my whole career or from the from this show? I there. Well, it's funny. Like the first joke that made sense to me as like, I feel like with comedians, it takes you years to find your voice and figure out like, what's authentic to you?
这太棒了。你写过的最早的笑话之一是什么，那是身经百炼、屡试不爽的？是我整个职业生涯的，还是这个节目的？我，这个嘛。有趣的是，就像让我开窍的第一个笑话，我觉得对喜剧演员来说，你需要花好几年时间来找到自己的声音，弄清楚什么对你来说才是真实的？
And there was a joke I did early on where I said, my girlfriend and I are living together and she's starting to think about having kids, which is exciting, because we're gonna have to break up. I've just decided I'm not gonna have kids until I'm sure nothing else good can happen in my life. And it was one of those jokes where,
我早期做过一个笑话，我说，我和我女朋友住在一起，她开始考虑生孩子了，这挺令人兴奋的，因为我们不得不分手了。我刚刚决定，在我确信生活中不会再有其他好事发生之前，我是不会生孩子的。这是一个这样的笑话：
whereas the first time where I was like, oh, it's not even a punchline, it's just a thought that sort of has an internal twist to it. And that's sort of how I try to think about jokes is like that if they don't even have to strain credibility, even, you know what I mean? The turn is authentic and the setup is authentic. Have you ever told a joke about something in your life
它甚至不是一个妙语（punchline），它只是一个带有某种内在转折的想法。这就是我思考笑话的方式，它们甚至不需要勉强去维持可信度，你懂我的意思吗？这个转折是真实的，铺垫也是真实的。你有没有讲过一个关于你生活中的事情的笑话，
and someone in your life who's mentioned it, but obviously starting probably with your wife, but like other people or anything like that where somebody's kind of like, hey man, were you talking about this and that they were like put off by it? I have it all the time, every time I'm on stage. Wow.
而你生活中的某个人——显然最开始可能是你妻子，但也可能是其他人——当某人觉得“嘿，老兄，你是在说这个吗”而感到被冒犯了？我经常遇到这种情况，每次我上台时都是这样。哇。
Like in other words, I think about that constantly, the sort of what can I talk about, what can't I talk about? Like I have that with my daughter, for example, because right now she's eight years old, and which is an amazing age, but I'm incapable of living in the present, and so my brain goes to when she's 15, and she's gonna be like, my dad
换句话说，我一直在思考这个问题，比如我能谈论什么，我不能谈论什么？例如，我和我女儿之间就有这种情况，因为她现在八岁，这是一个奇妙的年纪，但我无法活在当下，所以我的大脑会联想到她十五岁的时候，她会觉得我爸爸
is garbage. You know what I mean? And because I'm ready for that. Like I'm open to that. It happens. Yeah. And but my dad didn't have to deal with that. I grew up in the 80s. You know, we said it, but they didn't listen. You know, they were just like, is someone talking? And but when my daughter's 15, she's's gonna be like, my dad is garbage and I'm gonna be like, you're so brave, that's so true. How can I amplify your voice? You know what I mean? I'm gonna amplify it.
是个垃圾。你知道我的意思吗？因为我已经做好准备了。我对此持开放态度。这种事会发生。是的。而且——我父亲可不用应付这种事。我在八十年代长大。你知道的，我们说了，但他们不听。你知道的，他们只会觉得，有人在说话吗？但当我女儿十五岁时，她会说，我爸爸是个垃圾，而我会说，你太勇敢了，太对了。我该如何放大你的声音？你知道我的意思吗？我会放大它。
I'm gonna amplify it. So I think about that all the time. Like I think about, like even I have a joke about my daughter that I've been saying recently where like I say, Jenny and I went to see my daughter, her ballet recital. And we're in the audience, we're just crying and crying, because she doesn't have it, you know? And I can tell right away.
我会放大它。所以我一直在想这个。比如我想，甚至我最近一直在讲一个关于我女儿的笑话，我说，珍妮和我去看我女儿的芭蕾舞汇报演出。我们在观众席里，一直在哭、一直在哭，因为她根本没有这方面的天赋，你知道吗？我一眼就能看出来。
And it's one of those things where I'm doing the joke, and I'm thinking to myself, eventually, Una, my daughter, is gonna see this joke, and like, what's she gonna think? I don't know. Right. I made the mistake of working my kids and my wife into some stuff I was talking about
有那么一瞬间，我在讲这个笑话时，心里在想，总有一天，我的女儿尤娜会看到这个笑话，她会怎么想？我不知道。好吧。我曾犯过一个错误，就是把我的孩子和妻子揉进我偶尔在
on talk shows every once in a while. And my wife eventually just pulled me aside and said, that's no more, no more. No more. Come up with stuff that is funny but has nothing to do with me or the girls. And but that's you can't, at your life, your wife and your, your, your daughter, you, they can't take that off the table for you, right? I mean, I was going to say, I go through the same thing too, and I've done it before on talk shows as well.
脱口秀节目里谈论的一些事情中。最终，我妻子把我拉到一边对我说，别再这样了，到此为止。到此为止。想一些好笑但跟我或女孩们毫无关系的内容。但那是——你做不到，你的生活，你的妻子和你的、你的女儿，他们不能把这些从你的选择中拿掉，对吧？我是说，我本来想说，我也经历过同样的事情，以前在脱口秀节目里我也这么做过。
And my kids are older, like Jason's my older kids are older. And so you do that thing. And a couple times, like we've talked on the, on the podcast and I'm driving with my, and my kids are like, well, listen to it or they've driven it and they're like, are you, like, I can, it's just a weird because they are at that age now. And then they're like, hey, man, they're not even my partner.
我的孩子年龄更大，就像杰森的孩子们年龄更大。所以你会做那种事。有好几次，我们在播客里聊过，我在开车，我的孩子们听到了，或者他们开着车听到后说，你在——就像，这种感觉很诡异，因为他们现在到了那个年龄。然后他们会说，嘿，老兄，他们甚至不是我的伴侣。
It's my kids looking me like, hey, dude, are you talking about me? I'm like, yeah, sorry. Yeah, and of course you embellish a little bit to kind of make it funny. But no one knows that. And they know that. But they know that.
是我的孩子们看着我问，嘿，老兄，你是在说我吗？我说，是的，对不起。是的，当然你会稍微夸张一点来达到搞笑的效果。但没人知道这一点。而他们知道。但他们知道这一点。
And it's like, yeah, it's. I said this before, Mike, on the show, but I tried to do stand-up years and years and years and years ago. Horrible at it. Didn't know how to write. And one of my jokes had to do with ballet. My opening joke was, you know, they say ballet
所以，是的，这是。迈克，我以前在节目里说过这个，但我很多很多年以前尝试过做单口喜剧。糟糕透顶。根本不知道怎么写。我的一个笑话和芭蕾舞有关。我的开场白是，你知道，他们说芭蕾舞
is one of the most difficult things you can do. So I say, just don't do it. I don't, I feel like I feel like being the non laughter was intentional from Jason and well, yeah, I'll have heard that one before. Yeah. I keep it. It's not I keep I keep waiting. And there's, you know what I said, it's Sean one day, they'll be a punchline. Yeah. Well, first of all, Sean, first of all, a lot of people come on the show and say they saw good night, Oscar. I loved it.
是你所能做的最难的事情之一。所以我说，那就别做。我感觉，我感觉杰森和——好吧，现场没有笑声是他们故意的。是的，我以前听过那个。是的。我留着它。这不是——我一直在等着。而且，你知道我说的，肖恩，总有一天，会有一个妙语的。是的。好吧，首先，肖恩，首先，很多人来到节目里说他们看过《晚安，奥斯卡》（Good Night, Oscar）。我很喜欢。
I've got the program in my office right here. You came to the show. Yeah. And it's unsigned. I stood by the stage door and I just come back. Sean doesn't like the people. I'm such a big fan of yours. Thank you so much.
我办公室的桌上就放着节目单。你去了演出现场。是的。而且没有签名。我站在舞台门边，然后我刚回来。肖恩不喜欢那些人。我是你的超级粉丝。非常感谢。
I was, I'm just intimidated. I always feel like I'm going to be fan of yours. Thank you so much. I was, I'm just intimidated. I always feel like I'm going to be in the way. Yeah, I'm so honored to talk about on the show. We talked about that recently. We talked about that recently. You said, You probably, Mike, you probably felt it would be presumptuous for me. Yeah.
我当时，我只是感到畏缩。我总觉得我会——是你的粉丝。非常感谢。我当时，我只是感到畏缩。我总觉得我会碍手碍脚。是的，我很荣幸能在节目中谈论它。我们最近才聊过这个。我们最近才聊过这个。你说，迈克，你可能觉得由我来做会显得有些自作多情。对。
Just knock on the door and say, Hey, I'm famous. You're famous. Let's talk. Yeah. But I had I known I would have, I would have invited you. I had somebody sign it for you. Mike, are you the funniest guy in your family growing up or was mom and dad or mom or dad someone that gave you the funny gene? Close call. I mean, it depends on who you ask. My brother Joe, you know, a lot of times my people will
只是敲门说，嘿，我很出名。你很出名。我们聊聊吧。对。但如果我早知道的话，我就会邀请你了。我让人给你签个名。迈克，在你的成长过程中，你是家里最搞笑的人吗？还是爸爸妈妈或其中一人给了你搞笑基因？这很难说。我是说，这取决于你问谁。我哥哥乔，你知道，很多人会
ask my mom, they'll go, was he always funny growing up and she'll go, no, no, he's very serious. And then she'll say to me, she'll go, you know, you comedians are so serious. And I'm like, how many comedians do you know? You know, are you texting Ronnie Chang? Are you on an email? Chang with Roy Wood Jr.? Like, what is happening here?
问我妈妈，他们会问，他从小就很搞笑吗？而她会说，不，不，他很严肃。然后她会对我说，你知道，你们这些喜剧演员太严肃了。而我就会想，你到底认识几个喜剧演员？你在给罗尼·钱（Ronny Chieng）发短信吗？你在发电子邮件吗？跟罗伊·伍德（Roy Wood Jr.）一起发邮件？这到底是怎么回事？
But, no, in my brother Joe, I feel like his reputation as being the funniest one in the family. And he and I work together and collaborate on writing and everything, which has been very cool. So that's cool. It's a funny family. It's a, I don't know who's intending to be funny and who isn't. Yeah. You know, my, growing up, my dad, my dad's
但是，不，我哥哥乔，我觉得他在家里拥有最搞笑的名声。我和他一起工作，合作写作等等，这非常酷。所以这很酷。这是一个搞笑的家庭。这是一个，我不知道谁是故意搞笑，谁不是。对。你知道的，我，在我的成长过程中，我爸爸，我爸爸
very funny, but he would be, get very angry growing up. He'd be like, God damn it, I'm eating pretzels, you know, be like, is he angry? Is he hungry? What is the emotion being expressed? Yeah. There's a lot of fireworks, a lot of, it's a loud house. Yeah, yeah. Where was this house? What part of the world were we? Massachusetts. And how many, how many siblings?
非常搞笑，但他长大后会变得非常愤怒。他会说，见鬼去吧，我在吃蝴蝶饼（pretzels），你知道的，会像是在问，他是生气了吗？他是饿了吗？这表达的是什么情绪？对。有很多火药味，有很多，那是一个喧闹的家庭。对，对。这个房子在哪里？我们在世界的哪个地方？马萨诸塞州。有多少，有多少兄弟姐妹？
And the youngest of four. So I was sort of like the, is there another child? We're hanging on what part of Massachusetts? Shrewsbury. Shrewsbury. Yeah. And what's per biglia? What nationality?
我是四个孩子里最小的。所以我有点像是——还有别的孩子吗？我们纠结的是马萨诸塞州的什么地方？什鲁斯伯里（Shrewsbury）。什鲁斯伯里。对。那Perbiglia是什么？什么国籍？
Per biglia is Italian. Great question. Oh, it's Italian. Well, just because you're youngest of like, I'd like to put people in the boxes, Sean. Oh, so there's a Italian. You got it all in the background now. What kind of box do you want to put them in?
Perbiglia是意大利语。问得好。哦，它是意大利语。好吧，就因为你是老小——肖恩，我喜欢把人归类。哦，所以有个意大利人。你现在把背景都扯出来了。你想把他们归入哪种分类？
I'm past the box. What are you going to do? What are you going to do? What are you going to do? We're going to get some elbow macaroni. What are you going to do? You want them to forget about the question? If you shot Mike, I'm sorry.
我早就过了分类的阶段了。你打算怎么办？你打算怎么办？你打算怎么办？我们要去搞点弯管通心粉（elbow macaroni）。你打算怎么办？你想让他们忘掉那个问题吗？如果你开枪打死迈克，我很抱歉。
Now Mike, you know, being a guy who does what you do, well, I'm not offended just so you know, I'm not offended. Oh god, I did it. Doing what you do, you literally you work alone. Yeah, except when you're collaborating with your brother, brother, but so when you went, when you, when you did the directing stuff or when you're acting on something, and it's much more of a teamwork, right? A team sport. Are you able to switch gears easily,
现在，迈克，你知道，作为一个做你这种工作的人——顺便说一句，我没有被冒犯，只是让你知道，我没有被冒犯。哦天哪，我干了什么。做你所做的事，你真的是——你独自工作。对，除了当你和你的兄弟合作的时候，但所以当你去，当你进行导演工作，或者当你在某些事情上进行表演时，这就更像是一种团队合作了，对吧？一项团队运动。你能够轻松地切换频道吗，
or is it kind of like, on top of the... I do love that. I love the collaboration side of the field. Like I started when I was in college, I was casting the improv troupe, and that was sort of like, at Georgetown, that sort of changed my life. And I know you, I loved your Malania troupe and that was sort of like at Georgetown. That sort of changed my life. And I know you, I loved your millennia episode and he was talking about it.
还是说有点像，在……我确实很喜欢这个。我喜欢这一行的协作方面。比如我刚上大学时，我在组建即兴喜剧剧团，这在乔治敦大学改变了我的人生。我知道你，我喜欢你的木兰尼剧团，那在乔治敦大学改变了人生。我知道你，我喜欢你的木兰尼那一期，他当时就在谈论这个。
So, millennia basically was cast by Nick Crowell in the same improv group that I cast Nick Crowell in like a year before. Oh, wow. No way. Yeah. So, Nick and John and I have been friends for years and years. And then when John moved to New York, he came on tour with me. And so we've just known each other forever. But the improv community,
所以，木兰尼基本上是尼克·克罗尔（Nick Kroll）在一年前把我招进去的同一个即兴喜剧剧团里招募的。哦，哇。不会吧。对。所以，尼克、约翰和我已经做了很多年的朋友了。后来当约翰搬到纽约时，他跟我一起去巡演了。所以我们认识很久了。但是即兴喜剧界，
like I feel like that sort of formed my entire approach to creativity and creation and all the rules of, yes, ending everything. And like I made a movie about it called Don't Think Twice with Keegan Michael Key and Gillian Jacobs where it's a bunch of best friends in an improv group, and then one of them gets cast on sort of a Saturday and at live type of show, and the rest of them don't.
我觉得那塑造了我对创造力、创作以及“是的，而且”（yes, and）的所有规则的整个方法论。我还拍了一部以此为题材的电影，叫《不要想太多》（Don't Think Twice），主演有基甘-迈克尔·凯（Keegan-Michael Key）和吉莉安·雅各布斯（Gillian Jacobs），讲的是一群即兴喜剧剧团里的挚友，其中一个人被一档类似《周六夜现场》（Saturday Night Live）的节目选中了，而其他人没有。
And it's sort of about what happens in life when people realize that not everything's fair. What kind of, were you guys doing like heralds? And that kind of thing? Yeah, okay. We believe in it. Yeah, we actually, when I was in college, we were doing heralds. We, there was improv Olympic, actually actually came and did workshops with us. There was a, there was a group across town at GW called recess and they, UCB4 with like Aimee and Matt
这有点像是在讲述当人们意识到并非所有事情都公平时的生活。你们当时是在做什么，比如“先驱报”（heralds）那种形式吗？对，没错。我们相信这个。是的，其实，我上大学时，我们就在做“先驱报”。我们，即兴奥林匹克（ImprovOlympic）实际上来和我们做过工作坊。在跨镇的乔治华盛顿大学（GW）有一个叫Recess的团队，还有UCB4（Upright Citizens Brigade）带着艾米（Amy）和马特
and, and Matt and Ian came and, and did workshops with them. No, they did. Who came from, who came down from in prevolympic? So it was this, it was this group called Frank Booth, and they were fantastic. And it was, uh, this, uh, you know, so Sharna Halpern came. Oh, Sharna, of course. And, and it was, and Liz Allen, who ended up years later being, we hired her as the coach of our fictional improv group in this movie, don't think twice. And, and so yeah, I, the collaboration, like I love. And, well, not, well, speaking of that, Mike, you know, like I love, and well, now, well speaking of that, Mike, you know, like you're so funny and so such a brilliant writer and such a brilliant performer. Truly, do you have any aspirations?
以及马特和伊恩（Ian）来和他们做过工作坊。不，他们确实来了。谁从即兴奥林匹克下来的？所以是一个叫弗兰克·布斯（Frank Booth）的团队，他们棒极了。而且，这是一个，你知道的，所以沙娜·哈尔pern（Charna Halpern）来了。哦，沙娜，当然。而且，还有莉兹·艾伦（Liz Allen），多年后她成了我们在电影《不要想太多》中虚构的即兴喜剧团的教练。所以是的，我，这种协作，我非常喜欢。而且，话说回来，迈克，你知道，我喜欢，而且，现在，话说回来，迈克，你知道，你那么搞笑，又是一个如此才华横溢的作家和如此才华横溢的表演者。说真的，你有什么抱负吗？
What's that? There's a butt. But. But you seem like a dick. Like a dick. Like a dick. Like a dick. You're not a dick. I'm like a dick Like a dick But like other Italians I've met
什么？这里有个“但是”。但是。但你看起来像个混蛋。像个混蛋。像个混蛋。像个混蛋。你不是个混蛋。我看起来像个混蛋。像个混蛋。但就像我见过的其他意大利人一样。
Wait John I have it as a fan of the show could I ask Sean something which is oh yeah, is it ever? Are these guys ever too much on you? I joke we get we get pages of text after, you want to know what you guys, when you I feel it's all that. And it's true, it's true. A lot of the time. Yeah, it's pretty bad. And we will be right back. Thank you to FanDuel for supporting this episode of SmartLess.
等等，约翰，作为这个节目的粉丝，我能问肖恩一件事吗？那就是，哦，是的，会吗？这些家伙有没有对你要求太多？我开玩笑说，我们在节目之后会收到好几页的短信，你想知道你们这些家伙，当你们——我觉得全都是这样。而且这是真的，很多时候都是真的。是的，挺糟糕的。我们马上回来。感谢 FanDuel 对本期《聪明人》节目的支持。
The NFL regular season is wrapping up, but there's still time to get in on the action with FanDuel America's number one sports book. Right now, new customers get 150 in bonus bets guaranteed when you place a $5 bet. That's 150 bucks in bonus bets, win or lose. The app is so easy to use and there are so many different ways to bet, like live, same game parlay's, find bets in the new Explore tab make a parlay in the parlay hub the best way to find popular parlay's and more now I love to take bets on this show and smartless to see how many dumb dumb questions the other two can make before I make one smart one
NFL常规赛接近尾声，但现在加入 FanDuel——全美第一大体育博彩公司——还为时已晚吗？不，现在赶快行动吧。现在，新用户只需下注5美元，即可获得150美元的保证奖金投注。无论输赢，都有150美元的奖金投注。这个APP使用起来非常简单，有许多不同的投注方式，比如现场投注、同场连串过关（same game parlays），在全新的“探索”标签页中寻找投注，在连串过关中心创建连串过关，这是寻找热门连串过关的最佳方式等等。现在，我喜欢在这个节目和《聪明人》里下注，看看在我想出一个聪明的问之前，另外两个人能问出多少个愚蠢的问题。
Let's do it. So visit fandool.com slash smartless and make your first bet a layup Fandool official partner of the NFL 21 make your first bet a layup. Fandool, official partner of the NFL, 21-plus exclusions apply, C show notes for full disclaimer. We get support from Zip Recruiter. According to Forbes, January is the hottest month for hiring and business owners and hiring managers are on the hunt for top talent, which is no easy task. If you're currently hiring, you can probably relate.
我们开始吧。所以请访问 fandool.com/smartless，把你的第一笔投注当作一次简单的上篮。FanDuel 是 NFL 的官方合作伙伴，21岁以上。把你的第一笔投注当作一次简单的上篮。FanDuel 是 NFL 的官方合作伙伴，21岁以上，不适用地区除外，详情请查看节目说明。我们得到了 ZipRecruiter 的支持。据《福布斯》报道，一月是招聘最热门的月份，企业主和招聘经理都在寻找顶尖人才，这绝非易事。如果你目前正在招聘，你可能会感同身受。
It's challenging to find qualified candidates. That's why you need Zip Recruiter. Zip Recruiter's powerful matching technology finds the right people for your roles fast. And right now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartless. I mean, the next time I need to hire people, I'm definitely using Zip Recruiter. Discover the Zip Recruiter advantage.
寻找合格的候选人极具挑战性。这就是为什么你需要 ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter 强大的匹配技术能为你快速找到合适的人选。现在你可以在 ziprecruiter.com/smartless 上免费试用。我的意思是，下次我需要招人时，我绝对会用 ZipRecruiter。发现 ZipRecruiter 的优势。
Once your job is posted, Zip Recruiter smart technology swiftly identifies candidates that align with your requirements. Want a fast track top talent? Send personal invites to invite them to apply. As your rate candidates, Zip Recuder sends you more of the ones you like from the thousands of new job seekers who join the site. This month find the talent you need to fill all of your roles with Zip Recuder. See for yourself, I four out of five employers who post on Zippercuder,
一旦你的职位发布后，ZipRecruiter 的智能技术就会迅速识别出符合你要求的候选人。想要快速锁定顶尖人才？发送个性化邀请，邀请他们申请。当你对候选人进行评分时，ZipRecruiter 会从成千上万加入该网站的新求职者中向你推荐更多你喜欢的候选人。这个月，用 ZipRecruiter 找到填补你所有职位所需的人才。亲自体验一下，在 ZipRecruiter 上发布职位的五分之四的雇主中，
get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to our exclusive web address right now to try Zippercuder for free. Zippercuder.com slash smartless. Again, that's zippercuder.com slash smart.sss. Zippercuder, the smartest way to hire. All right, back to the show. I'm sorry, Shuffle. What was your question?
第一天就能获得高质量的候选人。现在就访问我们的专属网址免费试用 ZipRecruiter。Zippercruiter.com/smartless。再说一遍，网址是 zippercruiter.com/smart.sss。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。好了，回到节目中。对不起，沙夫。你的问题是什么？
I apologize. I'm probably way, can I do it? Have you ever forgotten a joke when you're on stage? Did you ever go out there? Did you have somebody have to throw you a line? You have a podcast. Have you ever forgotten your question during your podcast? What's your funny, What's your funnyest podcast moment?
我很抱歉。我可能扯得太远了，我能问吗？你在台上时有没有忘过词？你有没有经历过那种情况？你有没有过让别人给你递台词的经历？你有个播客。你在播客里忘过你的问题吗？你经历过最搞笑的播客时刻是什么？
Sean, these are great questions. These are really spot on. I'm crossing the law for they say them. No, have you, like if this was the 80s or 90s and you were as brilliant as you are now, they'd hand you a sitcom, right? And now if you weren't really doing those, that kind of thing anymore.
肖恩，这些问题太棒了。这些真的切中要害。我都快要为他们鼓掌了。不，你有过吗，如果这是在八十年代或九十年代，而你和现在一样才华横溢，他们就会直接给你一部情景喜剧，对吧？而现在你不再真的做那种类型的东西了。
So are you doing the dream that you've always, which is stand up and writing and touring and all of that? Or is there more that you want to do that you haven't done? First of all, I've auditioned ones for the role of Buster. They gave it to someone else, Buster. Yep. So Jason and Will just started to put you on the spot, but do you feel like they went in the right direction with that one? No way. Absolutely not. Who would still be on the spot, but do you feel like they went in the right direction with that one? No way. Showing still be on the air. If you will, I'd love to see, I mean, I don't know because I don't know what you did
所以你是在实现你一直以来的梦想，也就是单口喜剧、写作、巡演以及所有这些？还是说还有更多你想做却还没做的事？首先，我曾经为“巴斯特”（Buster）这个角色试镜过。他们把它给了别人，巴斯特。没错。所以杰森和威尔刚才是想让你当场出丑吗？但你觉得他们那个方向选对了吗？绝不可能。绝对没有。谁还会在节目里出丑，但你觉得他们选对方向了吗？绝不可能。肖恩如果还在播出的。如果你愿意，我很想看看——我是说，我不知道，因为我不知道你是怎么做的。
it. If you're prepared, if you remember at all what you did, I'd love to see it, Mike. Let's, let's, let's improvise a scene right now. Will you play Joe while play? Was it Michael? Yes, Michael. There he is. There's, there's, hey, hey, B Buster, could you please take your shoes off before you bring that mud
如果你有准备，如果你还记得你当时是怎么演的，我很想看看，迈克。让我们，让我们，让我们现场即兴演一段。你来演乔，我来演——是迈克尔吗？对，迈克尔。他来了，他来了，嘿，嘿，巴斯特，在你把那些泥土带进屋里之前，能请你把鞋脱了好吗？哦，我不知道。我不知道我能不能。我觉得我已经进屋了。好吧，那就跨过你的内心。看看周围。这是你第一次进建筑物吗？哦，迈克。
inside the house for us? Oh, I don't know. I don't know if I can. I think I'm already inside the house. Yeah, well just cross your inside. Look around you. What is this your first time in a building? Oh, Mike.
哦，我好像把衬衫脱了。哦，对。请不要穿鞋。只穿着皮带。哦，兄弟，再来一节。我的裤子掉了。而且，乔，你希望大家怎么评价？你是说，我们汽油用完了吗？
Oh, I seem to have taken off my shirt. Oh, yeah. No shoes, please. Just on the belt. Oh, and bro and take a verse. There go my pants. And, Joe, what do you hope said about? Did you say, way run out of gas?
看？哦，天哪，我觉得我的东西是——好吧，对不起。我太好心了。我太好心了。我太好心了。但补充一下，肖恩，回答你的问题，是的。比如，我曾为——我为
See? Oh, my God, I think my thing is. Okay, sorry. I'm so kind. I'm so kind. I'm so kind. But to add, Sean, to answer your question, yeah. Like, I audition for for I auditioned to play
《办公室》（The Office）里的吉姆（Jim）试镜过。我为《副总统》（Veep）里的乔纳（Jonah）试镜过。我确实，你知道的，我不知道那些节目后来怎么样了，但我对你现在做的事很满意。你知道后来怎么了吗？所有这些节目，迈克，它们后来都停播了。你知道，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不流，充满了即兴发挥和疯狂。但在2008年的CBS，那可不在考虑范围内。所以它变成了一个非常温和的迈克·博比利亚版，到了最后，我当时就想，我们拍了试播集。演员阵容简直不可思议。
Jim on the office. I auditioned to play Jonah on V by I did, you know, I don't know what happened. Any of those shows, but I'm fine with you're doing just you're doing. You know what happened? All those shows Mike they all went off the air. You know, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, had my brothers, it would be like something like a resivellment where it's like off the wall and improvisational and nuts. And at CBS in 2008, that was not on the menu. And so it became a very watered down Mike Burbiglia and by the end of it, I was just like, we shot the pilot. And the cast was incredible.
尼克·克罗尔饰演我的表弟，鲍勃·奥登（Bob Odenkirk）饰演我的哥哥。太棒了。在当时电视网的限制下，我们已经尽力做到了最好，但后来它没有被买下播出。老实说，这是发生在我身上最好的事。当时我心碎了，但后来我回到了纽约，推出了我的第一部单人脱口秀。
Nick Crowe played my cousin, Bob Odin, we shot the pilot and the cast was incredible. Nick Crowe played my cousin, Bob Odin, Kirk played my brother. And it was amazing. It was as good as we could do within the constraints of network TV at that time, but then it didn't get picked up for air. And honestly, it was the best thing that could have ever happened to me. I was crushed at the time, but then I went back to New York and I mounted my first solo show.
然后我继续创作了，你知道的，所有这些单人脱口秀，现在我正在做一件对你和你的审美品味来说绝对是靶心的事情，而另一个节目则不然，对吧？是的，这真的是一次大倒退。每件事发生都有其原因。我也有过类似的经历，拍过一部多机位的剧，那部剧差点毁了我，我也有过类似的经历。就在那之前，那是——是不是就在《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）之前？对。然后发生了那件事。
Then I went on to make, you know, all these solo shows and now I'm doing something that was an absolute bullseye for you and your sensibility as opposed to the other show, uh, he wasn't, right? Yeah, it was a real walk down really. Everything, everything happened for reason that way. I had a similar experience doing a doing a multi cam that was a, gonna, would have killed me and had a similar experience. And it was the one was it the one before right before us development. Yeah. And it had that happened.
迈克·马拉尼（Michael Maly?）——不，不，不，不，那只是另一部我拍过的叫《仍然站着》（Still Standing）的剧。不管怎样，我在试播集之后就被解雇了。所以当时我将无法参与《发展受阻》。布赖恩·卡伦（Brian Callan）当时在我被解雇时对我说——因为我很久以前就认识布赖恩了——他说，哦，怎么，你生气的不是你没有演那个该死的第五主角，每隔一集就走出来说“嘿，我的沙发到底怎么了”的那个人吗？好吧。
The Michael Mali. No, no, no, no, it was just other one called still standing that I did. Anyway, and I got fired after the pilot. And I was so it would have been unavailable for I would have been unavailable for rest of development at the time. Brian Callan said to me at the time when I got fired, because I knew Brian from way back in the day and he goes, oh, what, you're mad that you're not the fucking fifth lead who every other episode walks and goes, hey, what the hell happened to my couch? Okay.
你们，你们很好。开心点，别他妈担心这事。上帝字面意思——他当时就像是上帝在帮你的忙。现在，迈克，当你在我们的朋友吉米·金梅尔（Jimmy Kimmel）生病期间去帮他的忙、替他主持了一周的节目时。他得了夏季流感。对。对。这太棒了。迈克。现在，你，你觉得那是，感觉怎么样？那是你可能想做的事情吗？我太喜欢了。
You guys, you're fine. Just be happy and don't fucking worry about him. God's literally, he was like God's doing your favor and fucking six. Now Mike, when you went in and helped out our friend Jimmy Kimmel and you hosted this show for a week when he was suffering from a cold. He got an attack of the summers. Yeah. Yeah. This is great. Mike. Now, did you, did you, was it, how was that, how was that taste? Is that something that you would want to do maybe? I loved it.
我是说，吉米当然是最棒的，他，我是说吉米——不，不，不，不，他现在在说吉米·法伦（Jimmy Fallon）。回到我的问题上来。我们在谈论吉米·金梅尔。好吧。如果你这么说的话，迈克，我不知道，我把他和金梅尔搞混了。所以我当时在芝加哥。
I mean, Jimmy is the greatest obviously and he, I was, Kim, I'm from, no, no, no, no, he's talking about Fallon now. Stay on my question. We're talking about Jimmy Kimmel. Okay. If you say so, Mike, I don't know, I did made him a, Kimmel in here. So I was in Chicago.
事实上，就在肖恩带着《晚安，奥斯卡》在芝加哥的同一时间，我在斯蒂彭沃夫剧院（Steppenwolf），他们打电话来，我本打算飞过去当嘉宾，我当时正坐西南航空（Southwest Airlines）的飞机，然后我收到了吉米·金梅尔的短信，他说，呃，如果你帮我主持，我就给你换成私人飞机。对。没错。他说，我，我可能感染了新冠，然后五分钟，在五分钟后，他说，呃，你要当主持人而不是嘉宾了。
I had a matter of fact, exactly the same time Sean was in Chicago with Good Night Oscar. I was at Steppard Wolf and they called, I was going to fly out to be a guest and I was on Southwest Airlines and I get a text from Jimmy Kimmel and he goes, uh, I'll switch you to private if you host for me. Yeah. Exactly. He goes, I, I might have COVID, uh, and then five minutes, in five minutes later, he goes, uh, you're going to be the host instead of the guest.
紧接着五分钟后，他又发短信告诉我，你要采访汤姆·克鲁斯（Tom Cruise）。又过了五分钟，他发短信说，汤姆·克鲁斯取消了。哦天哪。这意味着显然他不愿意亲自完成所有特技。他不愿意从金梅尔一路走到博比利亚。当然。对吧？
And then five minutes after that, he texted me, you're interviewing Tom Cruise. And five minutes after that, he texted, Tom Cruise has canceled. Oh my god. Which means apparently he's not willing to do all his own stunts. He's not willing to go the distance from Kimmel to Berbiglia. Sure. Right.
不。好吧，他们早就该让马特·达蒙（Matt Damon）终于搞到一个节目了。但是，不，他们还是把他给挤掉了，哈？但我太喜欢了。我是说，是的，我是说，他，我是说金梅尔太棒了，但是做脱口秀，主持脱口秀节目，能够基本上与嘉宾进行即兴发挥，尽管，你知道，其中很多内容都是预先设定好的。要问什么问题，大概要给出什么答案。我猜你在那种环境下一定会如鱼得水。
No. Well, they should have allowed Mattmit to finally get, uh, get a show. But, uh, no, they still, still bumped them, huh? But I loved it. I mean, yeah, I mean, he's, I mean, Kimmel's amazing and, but do in a talk show, hosting a talk show and being able to improvise basically with guests, even though, you know, a lot of that stuff is, is sort of predetermined. What questions are going to be asked and roughly what answers are going to be given. You still, I would imagine would just soar in that environment.
我很感激。我是说，我喜欢把《解决问题》当成播客来做，同时也做我的单口喜剧、单人秀和巡演。我喜欢，我不知道。我觉得。你很棒。谢谢。就像，我觉得我很幸运，尤其是住在——
I appreciate it. I mean, I love being able to do working it out as a podcast and then also do my stand-up and solo shows and touring. Like, I like the, I don't know. I feel. You're good. Thanks. Like, I feel like I'm lucky, especially like I live in.
我只是说你想为哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）做深夜秀。对。好吧。他们会问，你在反抗这种狗屁吗？对。你表现得很有好斗性吗？因为这是CBS。对。
I just say you want to do the late night show for Christchurch. Yeah. Okay. They go, are you fighting this shit? Yeah. You coming in your combative? Because it's C.B.S. Yeah.
你永远不会为CBS工作。对。我不接深夜秀的工作。我不懂。你在搞什么鬼，宝贝？迈克，去做深夜秀的工作吧。首先，好吧，首先，如果我不提这件事，我就会失职，威尔和我一起演过《流行歌星：永不停歇》（Popstar: Never Stop Never Stopping），这是个，威尔，你永远不会听到，
You're never going to work to C.B.S. Yeah. I don't take the late night gig. I don't get it. What's your game, baby? Mike, do the late night gig. First of all, well, first of all, well, I'd be remiss if I didn't mention that. Well, and I were in pop star together, and this is something, well, you'll never hear,
因为你就是你，但当年孤独岛（The Lonely Island）在拍那部电影时，我就住在孤独岛的约玛·塔科内（Jorma Taccone）隔壁。他和安迪（Andy）以及阿吉瓦（Akiva）一起写那部电影，他对我说，我们要找，你知道的，他总是很兴奋，比如，我们要找最搞笑的人来演这个类似 TMZ（八卦媒体）风格的团体。
because you're you, but I lived at the time, the Lonely Island was making that movie. I lived next to Yorma Taconay from the Lonely Island. And he was writing that movie with those guys with Andy and Akiva, and he said to me, he goes, we're gonna get, you know, he gets riled up your maze. Like, we're gonna get the funniest guys to play this group that's like a TMZ kind of group.
而且会像这个人，那个。有一天他来找我们，他说，我们找了威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）来演那个——那个油腔滑调的角色。他当时高兴极了。然后在片场，我不知道这是不是——我不知道。
And it's gonna be like this person, this one. And one day he came to me, he's like, we got Will Arnett to play the, the love in character. And he was so happy. And then on set, and I don't know if this is. I don't know.
然后它就会像这个人，这一个。然后有一天他来找我，他说，我们请到了威尔·阿奈特来演那个，那个恋爱对象。他当时特别高兴。然后到了片场，我不知道这算不算。我不知道。
But then but then no, on set, and I feel like you got to take this compliment, you've you broke a lot of takes because people were laughing so hard on the set. I'm done. I need to see that movie and then I want to watch Hot Rod too. I wish you a double bill. I thought you were going to say that you're my, who my adore. You're my is one of the all time greats and you know you're his neighbor and friend and such a funny dude.
但后来，不对，在片场时，我觉得你得接受这个夸奖，你演的时候笑场了很多次，因为大家在片场笑得太厉害了。行了，我得去看那部电影，然后我还想看《热Rod》。我希望你能演个双片连映。我还以为你会说你是我，谁是我最崇拜的人。你是我……是史上最伟大的喜剧演员之一，你知道你是他的邻居兼朋友，而且是个超搞笑的家伙。
I love all the lonely island guys, but you're my, let me finish on talking about you. Yeah, no, no, no, no, no. Okay, sweet you're my sweet sweet you're my. Hey Sean, cool it, huh? I thought you, Mike, I thought you were gonna say, your man said we're gonna get the funniest guys to play these guys at the TMZ and then the next day he goes, okay, the funniest guys were unavailable. We do have.
我喜欢孤独岛（The Lonely Island）的所有成员，但你是我，让我把话说完关于你的事。对，不不不不不，好吧，甜心，你是我，甜心，甜心，你是我。嘿，肖恩，冷静点，哈？我还以为你，迈克，我还以为你要说，你老兄说我们要找最好笑的家伙来演TMZ的这些人，然后第二天他就说，好吧，最好笑的家伙都没空。我们只有。
We do have. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Mike, first of all, I'm just remembering we DM'd each other after my show. Fuck you, cool it, dude. I think that's cool, you know. Oh, I wasn't gonna bring it up. I wasn't gonna bring it up.
我们只有。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。迈克，首先，我刚想起来，我秀完之后我们还互发私信来着。操你的，冷静点，老兄。我觉得这挺酷的，你知道的。哦，我本来不想提的。我本来不想提的。
Okay, thank you. And thank you for saying such nice things about it. But I did want it because it's me, I want to say, worst heckler, worst experience ever. Worst heckler, oh god. I feel like honestly, you know, speaking of Steve Martin, like, I feel like his born standing up and interviews he's given over the years are the best advice about dealing with audience gone wrong stuff.
好吧，谢谢你。谢谢你对它给予了那么高的评价。但我之所以想说这个，因为是我嘛，我想说，史上最烂的起哄者，最糟糕的经历。最糟糕的起哄者，哦天哪。老实说，你知道的，说到史蒂夫·马丁，我觉得他当年的《站着出生》（Born Standing Up）以及这些年接受的采访，对于如何处理失控的观众这种事情，给出了最好的建议。
And he always says just react honestly in the moment. If someone shouts condom or some bullshit, just like, sir, I'm doing a show and thanks for being here, but that's actually not helpful. I have something prepared. And like, and like, that's sort of, that's, and what I find is that when you do that, is that it really just, it ends the thing.
他总是说，在当下就要诚实地做出反应。如果有人大喊“避孕套”或别的什么废话，就直接说，先生，我正在演出，谢谢你能来，但那个其实没什么帮助。我准备了别的内容。而且，而且，我发现当你这么做时，这真的就，它直接就把这事给结束了。
Because people just go like, oh, yeah, that guy's the asshole. And this guy knows what he's doing. Let's move on. Rather than rather than challenge or be challenging or aggressive back to what you mean. Yeah. And I early in my career, I was not good at this. I mean, I remember like, you know, 20 years ago, I remember performing in a casino. And there were these two guys in the front row
因为大家只会觉得，哦，对啊，那家伙是个混蛋。而这家伙知道自己在干什么。我们继续吧。而不是去挑战对方，或者以挑衅或攻击的方式回应对方，你懂我的意思。是的。在我职业生涯的早期，我不擅长这个。我是说，我记得，你知道的，20年来，我记得在一家赌场演出。前排有这两个家伙
who looked like maybe some kind of organized criminals. And they weren't smiling or laughing. They were very, very angry. And they were with these two women. And they were just talking and talking and talking. As though I wasn't there, as though there wasn't a show of any kind. Right.
看起来可能像是某种有组织犯罪的人。他们没有笑，也没有微笑。他们非常非常生气。他们和两个女人坐在一起。他们一直在那儿说话，说个不停。就好像我根本不存在一样，就好像根本没有什么演出似的。没错。
And so I kept being like, hey, maybe you don't talk, maybe go talk somewhere else. Yeah, yeah, right. And they just kept talking, talking. And finally, I didn't know what else to do and I was inexperienced and I said, hey, gentlemen, I feel like, I said gentlemen, I feel like maybe you should
所以我一直说，嘿，也许你们别说话了，也许去别的地方聊吧。对，对，没错。他们还是不停地说，说个不停。最后，我不知道还能做什么，而且我当时没有经验，我说，嘿，各位，我觉得，我说各位，我觉得也许你们应该
take your prostitutes. And I'm not standing behind the story. This is not, first of all, it's nothing I would say today. I won't recommend this. And the guy looked at, and maybe you guys should leave. And the guy looked at me in the eye and he goes, I'm gonna fucking kill you. And no one laughed. I didn't laugh. at me in the eye and he goes, I'm gonna fucking kill you.
带上你们的妓女。我并不是在为这个故事背书。这并不是，首先，这不是我今天会说的话。我不推荐这么做。然后那家伙看着，也许你们这些家伙该离开。那家伙直视着我的眼睛说，我要宰了你。没有人笑。我没笑。直视着我的眼睛说，我要宰了你。
And no one laughed. I didn't laugh. He didn't laugh. The audience didn't laugh. We were all uncertain of what was about to happen. And then he has squirted this guy out. I'm with my brother, Joe, after the show, we're gambling at Blackjack Table. And Joe yells at me.
没有人笑。我没笑。他没笑。观众都没笑。我们都不确定接下来会发生什么。然后他把这家伙赶了出去。演出结束后我和我兄弟乔在一起，我们在赌桌玩二十点。乔冲我大喊。
He goes, Mike, you can't do that. You get dangerous, you know. And you can't say that to people. You can't say people's wives are prostitutes. And I go, Joe, I, it wasn't my best moment, I get it. And at that moment, these two women come over and they go, are you guys looking for dates? And they're the two women from the front row.
他说，迈克，你不能那样做。你会惹上危险的，你知道的。你不能那样对别人说话。你不能说别人的妻子是妓女。我说，乔，我，这不是我表现最好的一次，我懂的。就在那时，那两个女人走了过来，她们说，你们在找约会对象吗？她们就是前排的那两个女人。
Of the show. Oh my God, no way. We'll have three professionals. Yeah. Wow. So you'd call this guy out. And maybe, and maybe, and maybe I was indeed about to be murdered.
看演出时的。哦天哪，不会吧。我们要找三个专业人士。Yeah。哇。所以你把这家伙给激怒了。也许，也许，也许我真的差点就被谋杀了。
Mike, have you, have you always had an eye for hookers? Yeah. Sorry. Be able to just pick them out of a crowd, literally. Just because it seems like people have a sevot for different things. But Mike, didn't you have a show called Spot, Spot the Pro for a while?
迈克，你，你一直都对妓女很有眼光吗？是的。抱歉。能够直接把她们从人群中挑出来，字面意义上的。因为感觉每个人对不同事物都有种第六感。但是迈克，你以前不是有个节目叫《寻找专业人士》（Spot the Pro）吗？
What? Spot the Pro. It's kind of, it's awful that he said that, but it's kind of fun to say. It's fucking great. I'm gonna fucking kill you. I'm gonna fucking kill you. I'm gonna fucking kill you. Somebody says I'm gonna fucking kill you. I'm gonna fucking kill you. Some believe it's horrible, but it's fun to say. Has anybody ever said that to you in that way or something close to that?
什么？《寻找专业人士》。他那样说有点，但这样说其实挺好玩的。太他妈棒了。我要宰了你。我要宰了你。我要宰了你。有人说我要宰了你。我要宰了你。有人觉得这很可怕，但说出来挺好玩的。有没有人这样对你说过，或者说过类似的话？
I think I've seen that said, with someone's eyes, but never verbalized. I had a guy once. This is a true story. I was like, I'm gonna kill you. I think I've seen that said, there were someone's eyes, but never verbalized. I had a guy once, this is a true story. I was a teenager and I remember I was in a McDonald's in Toronto. And there was a guy, there was a big line, two lines for the fuck, it was pre, you know,
我想我见过别人用眼神这么说，但从说出口。我以前遇到过一个人。这是个真实的故事。我当时就像是，我要宰了你。我想我见过别人用眼神这么说，但从说出口。我以前遇到过一个人，这是个真实的故事。我当时还是个青少年，我记得我在多伦多的一家麦当劳里。当时有个人，排了很长的队，有两条队，操，那是很久以前的事了，
whatever, 100,000 years ago. But there was a guy in line, in the other line, but ahead of me. And he was, there was something about him. he had the worst energy human I'd ever seen up to that point in my life. And he looked like he was just like, good, a fucking, and there was something up with the dude. And I was talking to my friends and I remember this like it was yesterday. And I was looking at him because I was like, well, this fucking, in my mind, I'm thinking,
管他呢，十万年前吧。但队伍里有个人，在另一条队里，但在我前面。他身上有某种特质。他有着我这辈子见过的最让人感到恶劣的人类能量。他看起来就像是，靠，一个他妈的，那家伙身上有点不对劲。我当时在跟我的朋友说话，我记得这事就像发生在昨天一样。我看着他，因为我想，靠，
this guy's a fucking murderer, like this guy's fucking, just the craziest looking dude, and I swear to God. I don't know how he was looking, he was facing forward, I was behind him, he turns around and he goes, don't fucking look at me. Oh, and then turn back around. And I almost, for real, for the first time in my life, I almost shatter my pants.
这家伙是个杀人犯吧，就像这家伙他妈的，绝对是看起来最疯狂的家伙，我发誓向上帝。我不知道他是怎么看的，他面向前方，我在他身后，他转过身来说，别他妈看着我。哦，然后又转了回去。我真的，这辈子头一回，我差点吓得尿裤子。
He said one happy meal, please. Yeah. Yeah. It was I remembered to this day. Don't fucking look at me. You imagine what kind of nightmares Mike would have had if that happened to him. Oh my god. Oh my god. I'm taking himself out of top floor, not a second floor. not a second floor. Mike, we're we've kept you six minutes over. We have. You make the time go so fast. Huge. Huge. You guys are this is a dream come true. I listen to the show with my wife Jenny and it's like listening to your three funniest friends and you don't have to talk. And today I had to, I got to talk, which is cool. But barely. I did. The thing while you were listening with her, little did you
他说，来一份开心乐园餐，谢谢。Yeah。Yeah。我至今仍记忆犹新。别他妈看着我。你能想象如果这事发生在迈克身上，他会做噩梦成什么样吗？哦天哪。哦天哪。他会把自己从顶楼扔下去，而不是二楼。而不是二楼。迈克，我们——我们让你多呆了六分钟。是的。你让时间过得太快了。太棒了。太棒了。你们这是——这真是梦想成真。我和我妻子珍妮一起听这个节目，这感觉就像是在听你三个最搞笑的朋友聊天，而且你还不用说话。今天我不得不说，我得开口说话了，这挺酷的。但几乎没怎么说。我确实说了。就在你和她一起听的时候，你根本
know, we had plans to bring you on here. Yeah, little did you know that we had talked about and you're, hopefully you're listening to it now with Jenny. I don't know. You guys and just we just again, we want to say hi to Jenny. She's a fan. Yep. We love your poetry and we love your project. And we're a fan of yours. And so, and Mike, I mean it when I said, you truly, truly have been on my list too for like a couple of years now. I'm surprised. And Will, where were you on that?
不知道，我们其实早就计划好要请你上节目了。对，你根本不知道我们一直在讨论你，而且，希望你现在正和珍妮一起听着呢。我不知道。你们，还有我们，我们再次想向珍妮问好。她是你的粉丝。Yep。我们喜欢你的诗歌，我们也喜欢你的项目。我们是你的粉丝。而且，迈克，我是认真的，当我说你真的，真的在我的邀请名单上也排了好几年了。我很惊讶。还有威尔，你在那上面排第几？
Yeah, Will. I mean, I'm going through a canyon right now, man. Do you know what I'm kind of breaking up? You're kind of breaking up. You're kind of breaking up. We'll call you back. We'll call you back. We'll call you back. Mike, thank you.
对，威尔。我是说，我现在正穿过一个峡谷，老兄。你知道吗，你声音有点断断续续的。你声音有点断断续续的。你声音有点断断续续的。我们待会儿给你打回去。我们待会儿给你打回去。我们待会儿给你打回去。迈克，谢谢你。
I know that you were us. I knew you were on somebody. Elses lists as well. You don't know who's on who's lists. Yeah. Wait, wait, wait, let me say one more thing too, because I listened to the show.
我知道你是我们……我知道你在某人的名单上也排得上号。你根本不知道谁在谁的名单上。对。等等，等等，等等，让我再说一件事，因为我听了这个节目。
In my special, the old man on the pool on Netflix, I talk about how my family wasn't, and I love you family growing up. Like we didn't say I love you. We said take, we said take care, which is sort of like a passive aggressive command. Like, I'm going to need you to do something for me. Take care, you know. And, but you guys always say I love you to each other,
在我的专场特辑《网飞的游泳池老头》（The old man on the pool on Netflix）里，我谈到了我的家庭不是那种……我爱你的家庭，在我成长的过程中。我们不说“我爱你”。我们说“保重”（Take care），这有点像是一个被动攻击性的命令。就像是，“我需要你帮我做件事。保重”，你知道的。但是你们总是对彼此说“我爱你”，
and I find it so sweet and meaning. Well, I just want to say that. Oh, that's real. Well, you know, what we love you now, Mike, you're part of it. I love you too. We sure do. Anything you want to say to Tracy, I mean, if you know the show, is there anything? Yeah. Tracy, I could recommend some of my Netflix specials in my movies and and I and thank you for being supporting Sean all these years through all that he's been through. Yeah, she's the best. I love her. Mike, do you have a recommendation for us for a good word to work into our buy?
我觉得这太甜美、太有意义了。好吧，我只是想说这个。哦，这太真实了。好吧，你知道吗，我们现在爱你，迈克，你是我们的一部分了。我也爱你们。我们当然爱。你有什么想对特蕾西说的吗，我是说，如果你了解这个节目的话，有什么想说的吗？对。特蕾西，我可以推荐一些我的网飞专场和我的电影，而且，谢谢你这些年一直支持肖恩经历的一切风风雨雨。对，她是最好的。我爱她。迈克，你有什么好建议给我们，让我们在道别时用一个好词吗？
Because I think we've never done this. Yeah, we're pretty tapped out. And since you're a listener of the show, you ever thought, I don't they ever use this word? That would be easy. Yeah, like, like, you know, you have children, right? Sure. Sure Sure sure. So So I would just say just think of your your favorite song or lullab
因为我觉得我们从来没这么做过。对，我们已经江郎才尽了。既然你是节目的听众，你有没有想过，“他们怎么从来不用这个词？”那会很简单。对，就像，就像，你知道的，你有孩子，对吧？当然。当然，当然，当然。所以，所以我会说，就想想你最喜欢的歌或摇篮曲吧。
We love you love you Love you Mike. Love you love you. Love you. Love you Mike. Love you Mike. Love you. Bye. Bye. Bye. We are clear Mike per by glia. Oh, oh, oh, very good. It's per big. Yeah. I'm just saying for the buy. Oh, oh, oh, you stupid ass. Stupid. Okay. Okay. You're a drummer than me. Good, you know what? You're a trumpet ass. Then I get to say it then. Okay. Okay, okay. If I'm so stupid, let's see if you're gonna work it in smooth. If I'm so stupid to you.
我们爱你，爱你，爱你，迈克。爱你，爱你，爱你。爱你，迈克。爱你，迈克。爱你。再见。再见。再见。我们清静了，迈克，用“拜格利亚”（per by glia）。哦，哦，哦，非常好。是“per big”。对。我只是说在道别时用。哦，哦，哦，你这个笨蛋。笨蛋。好吧。好吧。你比我还笨。好吧，你知道吗？你才是个大喇叭笨蛋。那轮到我说了呗。好吧。好吧，好吧。如果我这么笨，那就看你能不能把它顺畅地用进道别里。既然我这么笨。
I love that guy, Jay. I love you. He's so funny. He's so funny. Yeah, I mean, I watch his stuff all the time and I'm like, oh, that's, it's like new, but old school, like his comedy, like you were saying, like storytelling stuff. I don't see a lot of-
我爱那个家伙，杰伊。我爱你。他太搞笑了。他太搞笑了。对，我是说，我经常看他的东西，然后我就觉得，哦，这感觉既新颖又有点老派，就像他的喜剧一样，就像你刚才说的，讲故事的内容。我没看到很多——
I'm gonna call you out on this and I don't wanna do it on the show because Mike's listening, but that's not true. I, the other day I said, hey, do you know, Mike Pavilion said, who's that? On Trilett. On Trilett. And I showed you a special, and you go,
我要当面揭穿你，我本来不想在节目里这么做的，因为迈克正在听，但那不是真的。我，有一天我说，嘿，你知道迈克·帕维里亚（Mike Pavone）吗？你说那是谁？在特里莱特（Trilet）。在特里莱特。然后我给你看了一个特辑，你说，
what am I watching? And I said, you're watching Mike Pavilion, especially, and you said, I don't see anything. He's invisible to me. He's worthless and talent free. Turn it off. No, he is so fucking, he's so fucking man for so long. I agree. He's so, he's so fucking fun. But a lot of comics don't do that anymore. I mean, some of them do, but he, I love that he does the one-man shows on Broadway. I think it's really fucking cool.
我到底在看什么？我说，你在看迈克·帕维里亚的特辑，然后你说，我什么也看不到。他在我眼里是隐形的。他一文不值，毫无才华。关掉它。不，他他妈的太——他他妈的太棒了，好久以来都是如此。我同意。他他妈的——他他妈的太有趣了。但很多喜剧演员现在都不那样做了。我是说，有些演员会，但我喜欢他在百老汇演独角戏。我觉得这他妈的太酷了。
Really cool. And it takes, that'd be fucking hard as shit. Think about it, Sean. You just got off Broadway. Imagine doing a one-man show every night. I mean, forget. Can't do it. You want to do it again?
真的太酷了。而且这需要——这他妈绝对难得要死。想想看，肖恩。你才刚演完百老汇。想象一下每晚都要演一场独角戏。我是说，算了吧。根本做不到。你想再演一次吗？
Yeah. Jay, you were just saying. You're going to do it. You can't even make a speech at a fucking good friend's party. Well, but one man shows that you can't make a speech at a good, nah, you can't. I'm not good on my feet with a microphone on my hand and a spotlight in my face. That's it. Jason, Jason and I will the other night at this party ran into Gustavo Dutamel. Yeah, did you really? Yeah.
对。杰伊，你刚才说。你要去演了。你甚至在好朋友的派对上都做不出一段祝酒词。好吧，但独角戏你没法在好——不，你真的不行。我在手里拿个麦克风、脸上打着聚光灯的情况下，临场发挥可不行。就是这样。杰森，杰森和我前几天在这场派对上碰到了古斯塔沃·杜达梅尔（Gustavo Dudamel）。对，真的吗？对。
And who orchestrated that? And a wonderful, aren't you good? Wow. Somebody took a nap and somebody's home from Atlanta. Uh-huh. Oh my, I'll be in the room. You know what? But he's going to be tired soon and then hopefully someone is just going to put him
谁安排的这个？而且好极了，你不是很厉害吗？哇。有人小睡了一觉，有人从亚特兰大回来了。嗯哼。哦天哪，我会留在房间里的。你知道吗？但他很快就会累的，然后希望会有人把他
right to bed and sing him a nice long. La la bye. What, what? And you know who, you know who I hope the person who sings it to me is? Who? Mike Burb. Bye, Glee.
直接哄上床睡觉，给他唱一支又长又美妙的。啦啦拜。什么，什么？而且你知道谁——你知道我希望给我唱摇篮曲的人是谁吗？是谁？迈克·伯布。拜，格利。
We are, bye, bye. You got a double bye. You got a bye bye. I got a from somebody else. I got that from somebody else. Double bye. Double bye, bye. I got to buy buy it. I got to put somebody else. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy it. I got to buy it.
我们走吧，拜，拜。你得了个双倍拜。你得了个拜拜。我是从别人那里听来的。我是从别人那里听来的。双倍拜。双倍拜，拜。我得道别了。我是从别人那里听来的。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。
I got to put somebody else. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it.
我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。
I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it.
我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。
I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy it. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy it. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. I got to buy. Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Granteri. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen to add free on Amazon music.
我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别了。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别了。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。我得道别。罗布·阿姆朱夫（Rob Armjulf）、本内特·巴巴科（Bennett Barbaco）和迈克尔·格兰特里（Michael Granteri）。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 ♪]如果你喜欢《SmartLess》，现在就可以加入Wondery App或苹果播客中的Wondery Plus，抢先收听无广告版。Prime会员可以在亚马逊音乐上收听无广告版。
Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. My members can listen ad-free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wendry.com slash survey. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在您离开之前，请访问 Wondry.com/survey 填写简短问卷，向我们介绍一下您自己。Prime会员可以在亚马逊音乐上收听无广告版。在您离开之前，请访问 Wondry.com/survey 填写简短问卷，向我们介绍一下您自己。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。